There was one more game, like solo exhibition that we had to play and he just wasn't there.
Oh my god!
Okay, that's pretty funny.
We were in the spot to win the whole tournament, the entire tournament, but we got crypto ulted, altar pushed into a building and died like in three seconds.
It was the weirdest shit ever.
We died in literally like two milliseconds.
Crypto ult, altar kill, boom.
And then he just left.
He just... like he even went offline on Discord.
He didn't even say bye.
I just saw him disappear on Fugi.
I just saw his icon disappear.
Okay, that's pretty funny.
That's pretty funny.
Oh my god.
That's why he's my idol.
He's the funny.
He's toxic like you.
Yeah, yeah, he's my hero.
Why can't you be more like Zero?
I invented toxicity in Apex, to be honest.
Sure.
Like back in my day when I was competing, I used to flame pros.
Back in my day.
Okay, grandpa.
It's been two years.
That's like what?
20 years in internet?
Internet?
Dude.
One month is one year in internet.
Didn't Zero win two years ago?
It's been two years since I competed.
Yeah, wasn't Zero also like better than...
What are you trying to say?
Nothing.
But that doesn't matter.
I invented toxicity in Apex Legends.
You invented toxicity in Apex Legends?
Yeah, I remember the day it happened.
When we got contested by six Russian teams in Overlook.
Yeah, what did you do?
That was a dark day.
What did you say?
We won every single contest and teabagged the fuck out of everyone.
And kept fucking...
Kept being toxic until they left.
Damn.
Do we have to put the delay on for our team?
No.
What the fuck?
We're not nerds.
Even if he says we have to, I'm not doing it.
Yeah, we're not nerds.
We're not nerds.
Okay.
I'm not doing anything like this.
We don't need to put TSM in front of our names.
They know who we are.
They know we're TSM.
Team... team... slightly Minhera.
Only slightly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Locked and ready.
We're so locked in.
Guys, fucking ready up.
Ready up.
Just start.
No, shit.
My bad.
Yeah.
Hello, I'm here.
Yeah, yeah, Docu's here.
We can go.
Yeah, I'm here already.
Just start.
I should say that.
Who cares about team five?
Oh my god.
Oh, he's starting.
Oh my god, he's starting.
Let's go!
No, we're not.
Oh, they're back.
Exactly.
They don't need that guy.
All right, here we go.
I mean, why should we wait for one person?
To be honest, you were three minutes late at the time as well.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't really feel like you get to talk...
This man, this man was late...
When I got in, there was like 15 people not even there yet.
You can't say that.
Yeah, but everyone who's late doesn't get to speak.
You also told him to start!
You said the same thing!
I was first in the lobby.
You said the same thing.
You told him to start and move out this man.
Yeah, but I get to speak because I joined on time.
Yeah, and I just repeated what you said.
No, I repeated what you said.
We're not fighting guys, we're just having a discussion.
Wait, wait, wait.
Take the character.
I'm Bloodhound.
You play Catalyst.
For your...
Dita, for your upgrade, just pick the wall upgrade two times.
What was my upgrade again?
I forgot.
Which one?
Left side or right side?
I think it's right side and left side, but I'm not sure.
Just read it.
Okay, I'm reading.
Doki, your upgrade is I think...
I think your upgrade is...
Your upgrades are...
Fuck, I think it's something with duration of scan.
Oh, yeah, I remember.
The right one?
The right one.
The left one for me.
I'm left.
Alright, Dita, you're Jumpmaster.
No, no, no, no, peace.
No, no, no, no, not me.
I don't know where I'm going.
I'm waiting, I'm waiting my flag.
In case Macnum...
Guys, guys, listen.
Yes, yes, Imperial RPR.
We're gonna scan every single beacon until we have purple armor.
This is the strata.
What about the armor thing?
And we're opening every single red bin for turbocharger.
Oh, we have...
Every single one.
We have scan.
Yeah, that's why we're landing here.
We're gonna scan people and then we're gonna scan...
I'm gonna land in the far right.
Okay.
We're gonna scan people and we're gonna scan zone.
And we're gonna just fucking get purple armors.
No more blue armor bullshit.
Yeah.
I believe in us.
You sound so enthusiastic.
Yeah.
Wait, what placement did you end up?
Wait.
We got 10th in Mpex Medsec.
Wait a minute.
There were people here.
Oh, we're gonna win.
Ah, murder them in cold blood.
Like hello.
Wait, what the fuck?
Somebody...
What?
Who landed next to me?
Well, who do you think they are?
I wasn't even paying attention.
Oh, they're over here.
They landed there.
Oh, okay.
I'm sorry.
You saw objective.
I saw objective.
Okay.
I have a lot of ping today.
Yeah, what ping?
This server just went from 130 to 180 ping.
I don't know.
This is 84 ping to me.
This is East.
This is a new server.
This is supposed to be Dallas.
Is this Dallas?
I'm 84 ping.
Kuro said Dallas, but I think he's lying to me, and this is like an organizer trying to sabotage me.
Wow.
I think it's not Dallas.
I think it's just North America.
I don't know.
Dallas is NA.
Dallas is North America.
Scan the beacons.
Why do this?
We had both scans too!
What the heck?
We had both scans as well.
This is sabotage.
This is actually sabotage.
Scans are 100% spawn by the way.
Oh, okay.
This is not sabotage.
Dude, he's just being an asshole.
He's just being an asshole.
I think it's unfair because I have Havoc in Flatline.
I thought you had 3 hours!
Hurry up!
I have it in FET later!
Havoc in fucking Flatline.
And they restart.
I think this is targeted by the way.
Please.
Do they use the same server when we scrim?
I don't know.
Oh.
I'll just play like video game.
Wait, what placement did you guys end up getting for the JP tournament?
10.
We were like 5th last game but we were like if we won the game we would basically win.
That's why 0.
Altifor.
Yeah, and then we got...
Honestly, we got hit by the most toxic push I've ever seen in my life.
By which team?
Which team?
It was some JP team.
Call them out.
They crypto ulted us.
And then they alter-q'd behind us into the building and then Magibold us so we would double stun.
I couldn't even take out my Havoc.
I already died.
It was insane.
What the heck?
What haste that come?
Wait, wait.
What placement did they get though?
Probably worse than us to win this one.
What if they're higher?
What if they're actually higher?
We were owning solos.
We got 2nd, 2nd and 3rd in solos.
All of us were going crazy in solos.
Yeah, but then you ended up getting...
It doesn't matter how crazy you were.
You were still 10th place.
We don't have any!
You said 100% spawn rate!
You fucking liar!
Yeah, I lied.
So what?
What?
You said it was 100% spawn rate!
Quick, somebody crash right now.
Okay, you ult F4 right now.
Wait, why do I have to ult F4?
I don't even have F4 on my keyboard.
I use a Wooting.
Ult F4 then.
Oh my god.
It's...
It's your idea.
You do it.
What do you want from me?
You clearly want to do it.
You clearly like the idea.
So you should do it because you're captain.
No, I'm not.
I'm not going to embarrass my name with your ideas.
My idea?
It's our idea.
How are you going to...
No.
You're not doing this.
We had this idea together as a team.
You're not doing this today.
I'm not lying.
We have to figure out where we're hitting beacons now.
By the way, I'm reporting Kuro on LGS.
Never let Kuro organize.
He's getting fucking reported.
He fucked over our first game.
Never again.
Yeah, he's reported.
Bad for life.
Yeah, buddy.
Count your days, buddy.
You're done for.
You're done.
Ooh, gold backpack.
Never mind.
I don't have my guns anymore.
Can you open this?
Yeah.
Yeah, I will.
But we need to figure out what the fuck are we scanning.
I don't know.
I will go take...
Harvester.
Okay.
What about Harvester?
Oh, Evo?
Yeah, Evo Harvester.
I have a white backpack.
We can scan and...
We can get poor.
The Chi or Geyser?
The Chi or Geyser.
Long Sight scanned us.
Okay.
Long Sight better not scan us.
Because they're gonna get these hands.
What if they kill us?
Okay, whose team are you on?
I'm just talking about the possibilities.
You're like not bringing any confidence to the team at all.
I said what if, what are the plans?
If, you know, I look like a contingency player.
Like what's the plan if we die?
That's not, I didn't say we die.
What if they scan us?
You said what if they kill us.
No, I said scan.
Somebody is not paying attention.
Why is she lying now?
I think you are...
You just need to fix your ears.
I think I should change my VPN to North America.
Only North America.
It's better for me.
Yeah, you should.
Who the heck told me that last?
Yeah, yeah, RPR.
I think he's trying to sabotage us.
Oh, wait, wait, I'm in here.
I'm with RPR.
What the fuck are they doing there?
I fell down.
What did he say?
Dallas?
Like he's trying to sabotage us.
Guys, how do I get back up?
Where are you?
Hurry up.
We gotta go do shit.
I'm not even the furthest away from you.
Ditto is further than me.
Yeah, but she's closer to us.
She's closer to the gold than you.
Come on.
Where is... I don't even remember the gold.
Oh, okay.
Kill this guy.
I'm here.
Solo crack.
One guy solo crack.
No, no, you're good.
I'm with you.
We're here.
Are they zipping?
He's 15 HP left.
Blue armor right here.
On this hill.
He has charge rifle.
I win.
Nah, I'd win.
Wait, but I don't see him.
Cracked.
40 flash.
I don't even have an angle for you guys.
One.
He's ghost tech.
I don't even have an angle.
I think they came from geyser, so that means the zone is probably on us, right?
Yeah, maybe.
I don't even see it.
Yeah, everyone's here and here.
Yeah, everyone is coming to our side.
Okay.
Oh, so we have the zone.
Yeah.
We don't get to scan for purple armor, man.
Fucking hell.
I hate how that goes.
Where should we go then, RPR?
Just here.
We have no other option now.
Yeah, but like, where do we play?
Oh my god.
I should have...
I would play these two houses.
I should have killed him.
This is our home now.
Oh, they're fighting here.
This team is getting beamed.
Flash!
I'm going in!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
We're coming over.
Are we pushing?
I don't know.
Let's break the doors and try to poke.
Because these guys are flush.
What if they take our house?
Wait, wait, there's a guy here.
Yeah, yeah.
That guy here.
Behind the pillar.
He's cracked.
Careful.
I don't have much shield cells and batteries.
I have 16 cells.
Okay, goodbye, I guess.
Everybody's shooting at me, but I don't know where...
Let's get to the top of our building.
Oh, wait, there's a rampart.
On the floor of this building right here.
Alright, heading over.
That's a... yeah, that is a rampart.
Okay, let's actually go back to our original house.
I have one of my own house.
Okay, yeah.
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
We might need to kill these guys.
Oh, this is a bad spot for me.
I might die.
What the... Oh, no.
I'm good.
I'm feeling safe.
Okay.
Okay, we're gonna eventually have to kill that team because we want that spot.
To be honest.
Maybe...
We kill them now.
Dito, I wanna give you some cells.
I can scan in six.
Yeah, yeah.
Here, I'll give you cells here.
You want me to scan now or wait?
Yeah.
Scan as soon as you can.
I'm gonna get a right side angle.
Oh, they left.
They went to the left building.
Okay.
I'm gonna take this building now.
And I'm gonna break their doors.
And then we just wanna bully them.
If we have nades, we wanna just throw them.
Yeah, I have nades too.
I'm on high ground for this.
Let me mull the door.
Did you break it?
Yeah, I broke the left door.
I will try to...
They're over here.
Yeah, just play the scan.
Oh, I got...
They scanned me.
They know I'm alone here.
There's another team.
Oh, yeah.
I need help.
I need help with this.
I'm trying to cover you.
I knocked one.
Here?
Here, here, here.
I knocked one.
I cracked one.
I cracked the other here.
We need to focus on behind.
Yeah, crack the other.
Crack the other.
We can't let this team get close.
I'm gonna run out of... heavy ammo.
I'm gonna look in front of us.
I'm looking in front of us.
I'm letting Bloodhounds scan behind.
I think they can lay.
Yeah.
Yeah, they rez.
They rez.
That's fine.
They're running all the way back there.
Back to the car.
There's the last guy.
I'm gonna see if there's heavy...
I'm gonna find heavy ammo.
I need heavy ammo.
Yeah, I'm looking for ammo right now.
We're going out to get ammo from them, guys.
We don't have another option.
Okay, okay, okay.
I will throw my nade.
Yeah, yeah.
Throw a nade.
They have blue armors.
This is good for us to get purple.
They have lifeline, though.
They have lifeline, though, which is...
Oh, I can't go.
I can't go.
I'm here.
Almost killed Bangalore.
I'm still selling.
If we're gonna fully commit, I can now.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Wait, wait.
Nighty's pushing them.
I'm smoking in there, so smoke when you can.
I'm looking behind.
Oh, yeah.
They're getting red pushed.
Revenant cracked.
One of them got knocked inside.
Flash, flash, flash.
Are we going?
Yeah, look to third party.
Okay, I'm scanning.
I'm scanning.
Holy shit.
What the fuck am I watching?
No knocks.
There's no knocks.
They have lifeline res.
So just stay close.
Stay close here.
And wait for them to fight.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
We need the skills because we need ammo.
There's so much light, though.
I'm gonna look behind us.
There's a team that redeployed behind us.
Yeah, right behind us.
I'm trying to get them off our backs.
Yeah, we might need to kill those guys.
Fucking hell.
Maybe I have to change my phone.
Yeah.
Oh, this team is peeking.
This team is peeking at the wall here.
Okay, okay.
Who the fuck are you guys?
It is...
I got a Phoenix hit.
There's no team in the house.
Is that from the house?
There's nobody in the house.
Yeah, I scanned it.
Okay, okay.
We got the boat houses then.
But we didn't get any fucking ammo, though.
But there's people on the bridge now.
There's people on the bridge.
These guys run here.
Okay.
Okay, I got this house now.
Watch behind us because that team behind us is like the biggest problem for us.
I might just swap...
I'm gonna swap my gun and go...
I'm gonna swap both short range.
Because I see so much R9 here.
I'm gonna give you my heavy.
Okay.
I just see like all light ammo.
These guys are getting railed here.
But they got a package.
Lifeline package.
Okay.
Nobody's behind us.
People crossed the bridge.
We were going this way and this way.
Everyone's going that way and they're all fighting there.
I kinda wanna like do something to them.
I have only one bat and two cells.
I have two bats and six cells.
I have one bat and six.
If they fight on the right side there...
I kinda even wanna...
Look at them on the bridge.
They're gonna try and come over here.
Okay.
They're getting beamed.
Walking down there.
They're going up.
Can you hear her?
On my ping?
Almost K.
They're heavily split.
Oh she's not alone.
I'm getting shot from...
I'm getting shot from my back from the building.
One guy's so low.
I'm getting shot from behind.
We might have to go back to the building.
I have no heavy ammo.
They're so far.
They might have more ammo.
I'm so poor.
I don't know.
Is he on the left side?
He is.
Purple armor.
Okay.
My last two sales.
They have to come to us.
Wait, right?
These guys have to come to us.
We're good.
We have to chill.
Our issue is we have no meds or ammo.
We have to win a fight.
We can't peek anymore.
Where do you want me to scan?
I want to peek.
Just keep scanning the team in the big building or on the bridge.
Bridge direction would be good.
Okay.
What?
I have this much.
No.
I already gave you all my heavy.
I have three bullets.
Wait, I think we should go to the house over and use catalyst on the walls.
Like make catalyst doors.
Rita.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
He's looking.
So annoying.
Yeah, this door as well.
We're just relaxing.
Please don't hurt us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's good.
This door and that door.
I'm going to scan.
Should I scan at the big house?
Yeah, keep scanning them and like behind us.
I fucking hate that we got zoned because we have no loot.
It pisses me off always.
We're just little guys.
I hate getting zoned.
I changed my gun.
Are you changing it on RE?
No, you don't.
I have fucking 24 bullets in my hemlock.
But I have a lot of energy.
There's a Rita behind us.
16.
By the way.
Look at it.
Cracked.
First guy cracked.
Okay.
He's dead.
Nice.
They're right in front of us.
Be careful.
He's there still?
Are we going to get...
I just want to finish the kill.
Finish it?
No, they lifeline res.
Right here.
I'm going to bang ult right behind this rock.
Behind us?
Okay.
New team landed below.
They're going to fight.
Be careful.
I'll go back too.
I can scan.
Look at this bloodhound.
One on the bloodhound.
Flash.
I'm going to flash.
Stop shooting me in the back, asshole.
Fuck off.
We're literally helping you.
It's my last bat.
You have no friends.
Play on Ditto.
Scan these guys and let's see if we can kill them.
Okay.
They scanned us.
I have one cell, no bats.
This is insane.
I have one cell.
I have two cells left.
Two cells left.
There's a team on the house, by the way.
We have to pull in this team.
I kid you not.
I can bloodhound all of them.
Look at this below.
They're going to fight each other.
I'm completely out of fucking...
I can scan him in one.
I got one.
Scan, scan, scan.
Get that guy to my right.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm dropping down.
I'm going to try to loot some.
You guys stay up.
Okay.
I'll stay.
Do they have loot?
I need energy and light.
I'm trying to get as much as I can.
They're scanning me though.
I can scan anyone.
I'm looking.
I need some cover.
I'm trying to help you.
I can make you a wall.
I'm good for now.
I'm just going to try to loot this box.
I want to make a wall and go to you.
I don't think you can.
I need...
I have a redeploy.
Do you want to take my redeploy to climb back up?
I have one.
I'll use it.
I just need you guys to watch these dumbasses that are trying to fucking kill me.
You're fine.
I have two seconds of smoke and then I'm smoking.
Guys, I'm on the right side.
We might have to drop.
There's a team looking.
They're looking at us.
Play up top if you can.
I can't.
The other team is meeting up.
Then come to me.
Is there meds in there?
We're going to have to full kill this team.
I'm going to make a wall.
I will swap my armor.
I don't have anything.
I have one bat and 11 cells.
Come with me here.
You got to play here.
No choice.
Cells here.
Get as many nades as you can.
We can go back up now.
We can go back up.
Go back up in the corner.
The other side is not in the zone anymore.
They're not underneath that.
What the fuck?
I didn't get that scan.
Falcon, you can see us.
It's fine.
I have smoke.
They can apparently just see.
I was going to...
I'm all here.
Just chill.
I don't think that team can push.
No, I'm fine.
Just block us.
Block, block, block.
The back boat is...
It's okay.
How can he just do that?
Just play behind my knockdown.
Not yet.
They don't see me yet.
He's just staring at me.
Can you crack him once?
And then res me?
I didn't try.
Okay.
Try to Bloodhound scan them maybe.
Oh my god.
I can't fucking pick you up.
I used the shield res already just in case.
You can armor swap me.
I already armor swapped.
I already used it.
I'm going to heal it in my own smoke.
We got to go over in a sec.
Yeah, I'm taking your stuff.
Okay, I'm going to go over because this corner is a death sentence.
I'm getting behind this rampart wall to...
I have no more bats and I have 11 cells.
I don't have any shields for you.
This is ours.
I can give you shields.
I only have syringes.
I'm going to have to...
I'm going to have to bang ult this.
Okay.
We're going to have to play left side here.
I see a team right in front of us.
Right here.
I'm going to bang ult left side.
There's a guy here.
Solo.
We're getting poked at though.
This is my ult.
We can play on this.
Okay.
Play on me.
And we slowly move.
I knocked someone in front.
And I cracked like crazy.
Kill the guy.
He's alone.
Nice.
I knocked two people here in the smoke.
I'm going to go here.
Play the head glitch.
It's one guy.
It's full kill.
It was one guy.
Oh my god.
What do we do?
I knocked two people there.
I think they have...
No.
They full killed your team.
They full killed them.
I got the kills.
You got the kills?
Nice.
There's nothing we can do.
Their zone came on us.
We were so poor.
I actually just hate getting zoned.
It's so bad.
I hate it so much.
There was nothing we can do.
We got kills.
And sixth place.
We had to.
If we don't kill people.
We don't know how to lose.
If we didn't get...
If we didn't kill people.
We would actually be poor.
And the guys we killed were also poor.
So it's not like we got anything crazy.
Everybody was broke.
Guys.
I mean we made it pretty far.
I got one back and like four cells out of them.
I had one back too.
We did pretty good.
With how far...
With how broke we were.
We killed all three of them and got like four cells out of them.
That was crazy.
I didn't want to get zoned.
And that guy that saw us through smoke too.
That shit was fucked up.
Honestly I'm not gonna lie.
I fucking won't clip the guy through smoke right there in the end.
I'm not gonna lie.
I used scan team.
I smoked him.
And just won't clip him.
And my ult knocked one.
I'm not gonna lie.
God this Bloodhound is so rich.
He actually has meds.
That's not fair.
We got sabotaged by the game leader.
There was just so much we had to control.
With so much little resources.
That's messed up.
I bet you that first game would have been our winning game if we didn't get sabotaged.
Yeah.
We had two beacons.
We had red bane.
We had everything.
Yeah we had everything.
I had my gun load out.
I had everything I ever wanted in life.
Look at this meta dude.
Smoke, scan.
I mean they are rich.
They actually have loot.
It's not fair.
When we are broke we just have to win fights and take out the shit.
There is no other choice.
And this is also...
This lifeline team is the team that we know.
When they landed below.
This was literally the team we knocked.
But they got second place.
We knocked bloodhound and then they used lifeline res.
So we didn't get the kill for it.
And I wanted to finish.
That's not fair.
It's okay.
We killed the other team.
That tried to get in.
We did the best we could with the loot we had.
Yeah with the...
The situation we had.
We got kills.
And we got sixth place.
Let's go.
TSM could never do that.
The old TSM.
That's why we are the new TSM.
Yeah old TSM sucks.
Yeah old TSM fucking sucks.
They could never do something like this.
Yeah I mean...
Old TSM got 17th place.
That's why we are the new TSM.
That's all I'm saying.
We did good considering the fact that we don't have aim assist.
And we have no...
That's true.
That's so true.
So real for that.
We are so real for that.
You are so real.
Oh my god.
You are so real for that.
You are so real.
Say your truth.
Say it to the world.
Alright.
I did.
So I can fucking blame for it.
I need to get some coffee.
I'm fucked right now.
Is it Storm Point or still World's Edge?
I think it's World's Edge.
It's three World's Edge and then three Storm Points.
I'll be back.
I'm going to grab some coffee.
Okay.
I drank my first coffee in like six months for this tournament.
It's crazy.
First coffee in six months?
Yes.
Wow.
Alright I'm going to go.
I'm back.
Are we doing the same comp?
The refrigerator is right outside my room.
Are you getting iced coffee?
Yeah I'm getting iced coffee.
Canned coffee.
You know.
Fake coffee where it's just sugar.
Is that like... I used to drink just like canned coffees from Starbucks.
Like actual Starbucks canned coffees.
No it's like Japanese canned coffee.
So it's mostly just sugar.
With some caffeine in it.
Japanese canned coffee.
You have two options.
You have the sugary one or the black coffee.
Oh no the sugary one.
I'm having the sugary one.
I cannot eat black coffee.
That is crazy.
Like how do people swallow that?
Wait Dyrus is in this lobby?
Wait since when?
He's from Linksr.
Wait since when though?
I didn't see him.
I think Linksr didn't join so he got Dyrus to play or something.
Oh my god we have to kill Dyrus.
We have to.
I mean we can make it happen.
We have to kill Dyrus.
Dyrus is going to be like what the fuck dude.
Is he your friend?
Yeah sure.
Sure what?
I think we can be good friends.
I think.
Ditto do you know who Dyrus is?
No.
He's a ex-professional League of Legends player for TSM.
Ditto do you know who Dyrus is?
Wait I think I have ever seen him.
Dyrus.
Dyrus yeah.
He was pretty famous in League of Legends.
Yeah and now he's...
He's like what's the word...
He's wild on Twitter now.
He's wild and free.
He's bullied by Vtubers.
He gets bullied by Vtubers in tournaments now in Apex.
How the mighty have fallen.
He loves me.
Okay, we have two.
I wish someone would not disconnect.
I sense sarcasm in your voice, Ducky.
Yeah, my voice always has sarcasm.
But it doesn't mean I am sarcastic.
That's double sarcasm right now.
You're stacking it like a fucking...
If I get double sarcasm, that's like two negatives.
It cancels each other out.
Do you not know simple math?
That's not how it works in sarcasm mathematics.
That is how it works!
It's literally canceling each other.
What do you mean?
Are you some fucking PhD professor?
I literally invented sarcasm mathematics.
I literally have a PhD.
From where?
From PTSD.
Oh, hey, there's a triple take.
There's so many triple takes.
I'll take a triple take.
I shoot too much ammo.
I need to become Shiv.
I gotta carry stacks on stacks apparently.
I shoot way too much.
Well, to be fair, we had literally no resources going in.
Oh, I forgot the game audio.
Sorry.
Sorry, guys.
Can you scan the...
people beacon?
Right now?
Yeah.
Not even there though.
Alright, I'm heading over.
When you get there, can you scan the people beacon?
Alright.
This thing's right next to me, so I gotta get this.
I kinda wanna open the red bin behind us, but I don't wanna go back, so we're not doing that.
You're so lazy.
What happened?
No, because we have to rotate.
What happened to you?
When did you get so lazy?
It's not about laziness, it's about efficiency.
Our efficiency is not allowing us to go back.
We gotta go forward.
Look at this zone.
Yeah, but I have to scan anyway.
Yeah, hit the scan and start walking towards me.
Okay.
I'm like, no heavy again.
This game doesn't spawn heavy ammo.
Alright, scanning in 3, 2, 1.
Do you need heavy mag?
No, heavy ammo.
Ammo, okay.
I'm ready.
Oh, there's people here.
Okay, we can go for this and this on the way.
Alright.
And that should give us...
I have a lot of heavy ammo.
I have a redeploy.
Should give us a lot of you.
I need heavy and energy too.
I have a lot of energy.
I can give you 160 energy.
Alright.
I'm just gonna check these bins real quick.
Ooh.
I can give it to you.
I have like...
Run straight toward me, guys.
Okay, I got heavy.
I'm heading over.
Yeah, we gotta...
We gotta kind of move fast.
We gotta fast rotate.
There's 20 teams now.
Ditto.
Ditto, you're so behind.
I'm dropping 80 energy here.
Okay.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
Another 80 energy here.
Maybe even more actually.
Oh, nice.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
I'm going, I'm going.
I'm heading over.
We're so fast.
There's no bag...
Oh, fuck.
I got bags.
Purple bag, this shit.
There's a Havoc here.
Oh, purple bag.
Oh, I need Havoc.
I need Volt.
I'll take that.
I'll give you Volt.
Okay, I will...
Okay, okay.
Here, I take this Havoc, you take the Volt.
I have two short range, by the way, because I couldn't find any long range gun.
JK, I found a long range gun.
I need scope for it though.
Okay, we'll maybe find some in Fragment.
We want to hit the Juicer here and then we want to hit another people's gun.
And then after that, we want to probably go for Zone.
And this Zone is this...
I think it's this fucking annoying one, Northside.
Which one?
This one on my ping.
Oh, okay.
North of Epi.
Okay.
There's a bat here.
Can you carry?
Yeah.
Okay.
Carry the heavy too.
If you found a scope, tell me.
Okay.
I'm going to throw this energy.
Both of you need scope.
Okay, people are here on top of Fragment.
I have 2x, so I'm okay now.
Okay, there's people right here.
I just saw rotate.
They're going to rotate up the hill here.
Okay.
I would read a play.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have two read a plays that we can use.
Yeah, Bull Armors.
These guys on top of the fucking building are just going to fucking gatekeep this building.
I need to scan.
Someone's beaming me in my back.
We got to keep moving forward.
Oh, I see them.
They're really right behind us.
Yeah, yeah.
Get to the diner.
Keep walking with me.
They were here 30 seconds ago.
Okay.
Yeah, that's the team in front of us, brother.
Come with me.
We're going to go up the hill.
I have SCAD and 9.
Hopefully this team is not holding this high ground.
I need you to scan here.
All right, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
I'm going to scan.
Wee!
Nobody.
Okay, we're good.
They have Caustic Barrel.
Be careful.
Okay.
Okay, they scanned the Survey Beacon.
We can play from here.
Okay.
We're not last.
Let's go.
People died before us.
I love it when people are more incompetent.
Okay, dude.
Are they fighting on the right side?
Yeah.
Because if they are, we can maybe do something about it.
Okay.
I want to keep moving forward.
I want to get as far north as we can because I'm...
Fuck you.
Oh, that's embarrassing.
I'm not Bloodhound.
I can't see that.
I didn't see that either.
Okay, I heard a Sentinel from this side.
Let's keep moving.
Okay.
All right.
We're right behind you.
I need you to scan here.
I've SCAD and 18 because I used it earlier.
Oh, yeah.
Sentinel is at the house.
So we should be able to get here for free.
10 seconds.
Honestly, we could even play for 10 seconds.
Okay.
I'm going to scan the third beacon and then it would probably give us purple armor.
You want me to scan?
In this building.
Scan this.
I'm scanning.
People in there.
Yeah, yeah.
Watch them.
Okay.
We're going to play from here.
There's no other choice for us than to play from down here.
Okay.
I don't think we can get any more deeper.
What if they shoot us from the top?
They're not because I'm going to hold it.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
They also...
They have to hold their house.
Motherfucker, get off the fucking triple take.
Where are they?
Here?
On the roof.
Yeah, on the roof.
I don't see them on the roof.
If that team is too...
Oh, wait.
I see a team going left side inside the climate dash.
Look at them.
Watch them.
It's two teams, I think.
Yeah, yeah.
It is.
By the way, I missed every shot.
I haven't done...
One hit?
Guys, I have not played the 30-30 in too long.
Get fucked.
Motherfuckers.
Oh, no.
I haven't shot a 30-30 in a long time.
Be careful with the fucking...
I'm not going to...
Did you see any team?
Did you see any team on top?
No, there is a team in this house right here.
Dokie, I want you to keep scanning in this direction behind us in case anyone is trying to walk up to us.
We just need to know if there is people trying to contest us.
Okay.
Okay, we go on top.
We go on top.
I can give a two time scope.
I have a two X.
I'm just not hitting shots.
You want two to four?
Oh, shit.
Maybe 2-4 is better for me.
Someone is evacing and this time I'm gonna watch it.
I heard a fucking evac.
Where the fuck... Oh they're coming straight for us I think.
They're flying over us.
Red armor is already.
What the fuck?
They're gonna fight.
No, they're not.
They're definitely lining up people, Red.
They might be... They might just got from walking around and scanning.
Yeah, no.
These guys are just ripping scans of cooldown.
Honestly, we're like one scan of purple as well, so...
We just didn't get a chance to scan anything.
But where's end zone?
I guess we could have an overlook.
Woah.
End zone is somewhere around us.
I'm not sure exactly.
It's either pulling to climate test or coming back to us.
Yeah, they're fighting in the bottom here.
Yeah, they're pulling to climate test or coming back to us.
Like full fighting?
I don't know, I saw like poking down there, but, and they were running at the building.
I keep looking at that.
God, there's too many places to look at.
Aaaaah.
Focus, focus on looking below and scanning behind us.
That's all you got to do.
There's a team on top of Overlook Tower.
They're fighting over there.
He threw a fuse grenade.
Why did I get shot?
Can this guy triple-dive fuck off?
Oh that's your chase, I'm not...
I just got hit around the corner.
Yeah.
I smoked him.
He just picks the door always.
Really annoying.
Leave us alone!
Go fucking destroy your fence.
We kinda have to...
Save meds.
So the same shit doesn't happen from last game.
Yeah, they're getting shot too.
Maybe you can pick up a killer too.
I think they're fighting here.
Yeah, they're full fighting here.
Come here, Doki.
Look at this.
I will hit a shot.
I swear to god.
You wanna swap?
You wanna give me repeater and I give you hemlock?
No, I will hit a shot.
I swear.
In this corner, look.
Guys.
Look at these guys.
Oh, he's dead.
One dead.
Guys, maybe I'm just...
Maybe I'm just bad.
There's so many teams here.
I don't know what to look at.
There's one more team up here.
Okay.
We have to keep these guys and all of this entire side.
Because we have this good side over here.
Okay.
Let's do that.
I'm waiting.
I'm just gonna keep smoking this house.
Oh, there's a guy behind this rock.
There's like three teams here.
Wait, it got scanned by somewhere.
What?
Probably really far.
Can you scan this direction?
It's not flying.
I didn't see anybody.
It has to be far because I didn't get scanned.
Oh my god.
I hit two shots, guys.
These guys are dead.
These guys have to die.
He's in zone.
What the fuck is he living?
I cracked him.
He has to be low.
Yeah, he's... Oh, he's dead.
Nice, Zito.
They're rising.
They're trying to rez.
One more.
Nice one.
They should be able to rez though.
Yeah, they're trying to rez in here.
I don't think so.
They're getting shot from every side.
I don't think they can.
I didn't get my kill.
They crawled inside, I think.
Yeah, they're rez- they are rez- they are rez-ing.
I see them rez-ing.
Stop shooting him.
I'm fucking ulting them.
I don't give a fuck.
They got the rez.
Yeah, yeah.
I saw the rez going off.
What the heck?
How can they?
How is no one beaming these guys?
He just stopped.
That's actually crazy.
Maybe they didn't want to give us a kill.
Maybe.
Oh, yeah.
They're still here.
Yeah, yeah.
They're inside.
I got my purple.
I can't believe it.
Oh, they're rotating.
They're rotating out.
They're rotating in.
These guys are gonna die, I think.
Nobody's shooting them.
Yeah, yeah.
Look at the bloodhound.
Last guy.
Right here.
I'm reloading.
Yeah, he's going- He has to die.
20.
Mark, can I get- Oh, wait.
Behind us.
Oh.
He got shot from behind.
I'm dropping.
I'm dropping here.
That's so unlucky.
We're too busy looking in front.
Yeah, they know they walked up to us.
I can't believe that they too rotated so easily.
If you can come to me, Ditto, it's kinda okay.
Where can I rat here?
Oh my gosh.
Sayonara.
Can I go to you?
I wanna go above us somehow.
Do you have- I have ball.
Ditto?
What?
Have ball?
Come here and evac here so we can go above here.
Okay.
All the time.
Come to me and just put evac.
We have to go up here.
So come here.
Oh my god.
Ditto is so far.
No, no.
She's fine.
She just has to cross the lava.
You got this, Ditto.
They can't hear you.
Put evac here.
They're deaf.
And we jump up here on the rock, okay?
Okay.
And we play here.
Oh.
I like how Ditto is the one that still got shot.
And be careful above.
You actually had it.
How are you shooting me?
You're literally smoked.
I have no heavy ammo, buddy.
Get top five for me.
Oh man, I had all the heavy ammo in the world.
I can't give you the bomb.
Man, if only the bloodhound didn't die.
We can't make sound here, Ditto.
Huh?
Ditto, just crouch here.
We can't make sound.
Be a rat.
If the team above us peeks, we die.
It's rat time.
We have to rat here until someone drops on us and then we kill them.
Okay.
I think there is a team here in this corner.
Yeah, there is.
Look at them.
They're going to fight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They will.
Okay, we don't kill this guy.
Don't shoot.
Oh, never mind.
Okay, okay.
That's it.
I gripped them enough.
I cracked two.
Okay.
They're full-filed.
Oh, we got scanned.
We got scanned by...
I didn't get scanned.
Only you.
They'll think she's a solo.
Because they fucking hate you.
I don't know.
I lost with you.
They didn't scan me.
They just hate you.
Is it a bot?
Maybe it's a bot?
I mean, you just say you're getting scanned and then it didn't pick up.
I don't know.
I think I was...
I was a little bit in front of you.
That's why.
Okay, they finished this fight.
I believe in top five.
Maybe top four.
It would be better.
I think we're gonna be a little wild.
Now I got scanned.
It's max range scan.
They're scanning from like here.
It's max range.
They're right above us.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think we're really good here.
If we just...
We're gonna walk here.
They're right above us.
They're looking over.
Careful.
Don't let them see.
Yeah, they saw me.
They saw me.
Oh, they ulted.
Fuck them.
But they have Bloodhound ult.
Won't they be able to see that?
Oh, they're rotating.
I tried.
I think they're dying.
Those guys rotated.
Sita, we're gonna play like here.
Okay.
They're right above us.
Careful.
Look at this guy fighting.
Fighting.
Oh, a guy beaming me from the left side.
God, this is annoying.
Everybody wants to kill you.
Do you not have an arena play?
Is he up here?
No, no arena play.
Now I'm lagging all of a sudden.
No!
Oh my gosh, this is intense.
Sit where I am.
How many shield cells do you have left, Ditto?
Two.
Okay, one left.
It's okay.
I have... I can give you some.
Okay.
Nice.
I'm gonna bang ult here.
Uh-huh.
I can't even ping it.
It's okay.
They shoot another team.
This team is gonna get beamed from right side.
Uh-huh.
Like, look at this team.
Look at this team.
Oh, what the fuck?
How can you see me, dude?
Just doesn't like you.
Alright, I'm gonna bang ult in here.
I'm full healing and we're gonna play right side slow.
Okay.
Nade.
Oh, dude.
Oh, no.
I'm so... I'm lagging.
I can't even hit... like, he's teleporting.
Oh.
I didn't see that.
Oh, nice.
She's actually teleporting.
That's insane.
Wait, they're teleporting?
That fucking sucks.
Yeah, for me.
That's so unlucky.
Yeah, everyone's teleporting.
This is insane.
Yeah.
Is it still storming or...?
No, I don't know what's fucking going on.
We're back.
Alright.
Hey, we got top five.
No, that was Darius' team.
Yeah, we got top five.
Yeah.
Wait, I think you knocked Darius.
Oh, wait, he did.
He knocked Darius.
You know what?
That's great.
That's all I care about.
And we got top five.
Oh, we got zero... we had zero kills for top five?
We didn't kill anybody?
I'm surprised that we didn't kill anybody.
Yeah.
I guess we just... we knocked, like, a lot of people.
Yeah, we didn't get any kill.
Yeah.
I know.
Our PR is pulling a zero.
He's gonna ult at four.
What the fuck was that Bangalore banner?
That's Lynxer.
And he's been doing pro league.
Not a full VTuber tournament, guys.
Because I think there's not enough VTuber Apex players in NA.
Back.
Welcome back.
Did I get any kills for that?
Did you fix... no, we didn't get zero.
I would win that last fight if I'm not lagging.
Everything's fucking teleporting.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I could tell.
The first mag was not very inspirational.
I should have used my ult.
On my screen, that first mag was all over him.
Literally, aimed straight at him.
Yeah, yeah.
On my POV, it was not inspirational.
Shut up.
My POV is literally a fullness.
He was teleporting, so where I was shooting, he wasn't there.
This shit again.
I'm tilted.
What?
Did you fix it?
Or...
I don't know.
What did you do?
I literally don't know.
Did you do anything to fix it or nah?
I turned off everything in my house from Wi-Fi.
I'm gonna switch my VPN as well.
Maybe.
Maybe that helps.
Tell the organizer to do one game in Europe.
I mean, half the team is EU anyway, so...
Half the tournament.
More than I should know.
One third of people in this tournament are EU anyway, so might as well.
I'm fine with NA.
As long as I'm not lagging.
Like, when people start teleporting, I can't play the game.
I mean, I can't hit people.
How am I supposed to hit people when I can't see where they are?
They're not...
Like, where I'm shooting, they're not there.
Change the server.
I don't know if switching to EU would help.
Man, that's unlucky.
Because it always happens, like, in the second or third game for you.
Because it'll be okay and then suddenly, bam.
It was fine in the morning.
I played an entire tournament today in the morning.
It was completely fine.
Oh my gosh, sabotage.
Maybe he is DDoSing you.
Maybe we are getting sabotaged.
Alright.
Yay!
Game will restart.
What do you mean, game will restart?
What?
What do you mean?
Please announce new contest.
Game will restart.
Oh shit, wait, you're not even in the fucking lobby.
Wait a minute.
Yeah, I have to restart my game.
Hmm.
What does he mean by game will restart?
I don't know.
I hope he's not restarting a whole game.
He's gonna keep us in the 4AM or what?
No, they cannot.
I told him.
I was like, I'm leaving at 3.
Like, you literally can't.
I literally cannot.
I was like, if I'm doing this tournament, I have to leave at exactly 3.
Oh, so IPN is grieving.
That's what's going on.
Wait, how so?
Because apparently you need to announce a contest and they contested without announcing it.
Oh!
Oh wait, who did he grief?
I don't know.
Whoever lands Overlook, I think.
Oh, so they're not gonna count that game?
No, they're counting it.
But he said moving onwards.
If that happens again, he's not gonna count it.
Oh, that sucks for that team in Overlook.
That sucks for them.
They got fucking griefed.
They should like deduct points for that team.
IPN should get minus 40.
Yeah, yeah.
They should deduct points.
IPN should get minus 40 points so you can't win.
At all.
Like no matter how many points they get.
You cannot get past top 10.
Because you griefed.
You ruined the game for everybody else.
Who's IPN playing with?
Fruit and Zero.
Fruit and Zero?
Oh my god.
Fruit and Zero and IPN are griefing.
That's insane.
They're griefers.
I know.
That's what I'm saying.
They should minus deduct points.
Wow.
Why are they playing with two pros and griefing?
I know, right?
No.
Two pros and griefing is crazy.
I know.
You gotta do the honorable thing and have one pro and griefing.
But we're not griefing.
Griefing our own team, maybe.
Okay, well.
Ditto, carry us.
Let's fucking get beacons.
Okay.
Ditto, carry.
Carry everyone.
Yeah.
Ditto, what happened?
You used to kill everybody.
What happened?
Don't gaslight her.
I'm not gaslighting her.
I'm just gonna kill her.
I follow RPRs all day.
You're supposed to give her confidence.
RPRs making you a worst player.
How am I worse?
I literally have the most kills in the air.
And I'm not yearly.
I don't know.
She said she's literally following you and she's not getting kills.
That's what she said.
See?
She agreed.
I'm gonna lose my mind.
I'm useless again.
How many pings do you have in NA?
You should have Blaze ping more than me.
Well, the problem is not the ping.
I have 150 ping and it jumps on 200.
Then I have 150 and it jumps on 200.
And then makes everyone teleport.
It's your internet.
It can't be my internet.
I literally called my company twice to full restart everything and they did.
And my stream is not lagging.
How do you know they did it?
Because everything went down for like half an hour.
Maybe they just turned it off but they didn't.
I don't know but...
Oh, I fucked up my landing so I'm gonna steal your loot.
I don't know what's going on.
I'm gonna steal people's loot.
I don't know how to fix it even.
Oh, thank god I got a hemlock this time.
What's your no idea?
Maybe it's just a...
It's just Apex but...
It happened to me in Valorant the other day as well.
And I don't think it's fixed.
But to be honest, Valorant...
I was...
I was playing...
Yeah, but that was before I fixed it.
On Valorant I was playing on like an NA server with like 200 ping so it's kinda...
Could have been disused.
Oh, 3x.
Is RPL still teleporting for you or is it fixed now?
No, it's not fixed.
It's never gonna be fixed.
No...
How much time do you have?
Ooh...
Can you guys scan?
Okay.
Actual gameplay sabotage.
Oh, actually I'll take that.
I forgot I'm running hemlock.
I'm dropping a 3x if anybody wants it.
I want it.
I want any scope.
You want a 2x?
I have an extra 2x.
Yeah.
2x, 2x.
I'll take anything.
Alright.
I'm heading over.
We have zone.
We have zone again?
Yes.
We have a zone again.
No!
It's like we should play like from this side where you guys are.
So stay there.
I'm gonna get us some Evo charge here.
Here?
Yeah.
Like on this building or this height but I think building is probably easier.
Okay, I'm gonna craft it.
Okay.
I'm gonna craft it.
I got 3x.
Oh, you have 3x?
Okay.
I'll keep my 2x.
I'll have you go grab that 3x.
I need sculpture.
Nice.
I have 3 bats and 8 cells.
3x.
I have 2x12.
I didn't really find a lot of bats at all.
And I can't find a Havoc.
I can...
Oh, wait.
Wait, we...
Is...
Who's getting the...
Are you getting the Harvester or are we getting it?
Yeah, I mean, if you can get it but don't die for it.
I already got one of them.
I'll get the other then.
Wait, shouldn't...
I feel like you should be getting this, not me.
I'm way too far away to get it.
Oh, okay.
Oh, sorry.
You are...
Oh, somebody was here.
Somebody was here.
Probably tree team got the Harvester.
Oh, okay.
I got it.
Okay, nice.
I mean, we...
Our only option is really just playing zone.
We don't really have much one option here.
We're just gonna live here.
It's okay.
We're not gonna be last.
Somebody's dying already.
Yay!
I'm pretty sure it ends on this bridge, like right there.
All right.
Should we go to that bridge or stay here?
No, no, no.
I wanna play from like this corner here.
Those walls are really good.
Okay.
That's what...
I'm okay.
I'm gonna check.
Yeah, that's why I wanna play from this building and the walls.
I hate holding these walls because like you just get needed.
I like pushing it more than holding it.
I don't see anybody yet.
I'm gonna put four soldiers.
Oh.
Over there.
I see them.
And they see us too.
What the fuck?
Are they coming?
Oh, he came from...
These guys came from Geyser.
Geyser?
Or was it...
It came from...
It helped Sean's life though.
Geyser, big mod.
These guys came from big mod because he has the paintball gun.
Oh, big mod.
Okay.
Yeah.
Did you hit the...
Oh, no.
What?
We didn't have people scan, did we?
No, we didn't.
Yeah.
I'm checking if anybody reapplies to us.
Adita, you play there and play safe.
Put all your Qs everywhere.
We're gonna play roof and just look for the...
We're gonna look around and try to get information.
When it gets like...
When a lot of people start getting here, we're just gonna play here.
Adita's gonna play there.
And then if it gets like dicey, we just run to her.
Okay.
And play from Adita's side.
Like we wanna...
We don't play those walls over there.
Okay.
And if we can keep this high ground, we want to, but if we can't, we'll just give it up and play walls instead because these walls are pretty much gonna win us the game.
Nobody's rotated to us yet.
Yeah.
Oh, team over here.
They're very far.
They're very slow.
They're just playing edge, I guess.
Yeah.
I'm like...
Cause like usually zone teams would be here already.
So I'm like surprised I don't see anybody yet.
I don't even see any redeployers.
Oh!
The team jump over here.
How close?
Where the fuck?
Where I'm pinged.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Purple armor.
These guys are pretty good.
They're playing super slow.
What the fuck?
They're just taking scan... like a million... they can scan and shit.
Look to my left.
Oh, why is the spawn so low?
That guy is flashed by the way.
This guy.
Yeah.
This is bottom.
Look at this bottom now.
Did I hit him?
He's gonna move.
Yeah.
Stop shooting.
I'm looking to your left.
I'm gonna make sure...
Oh, there's a team coming... rotating in behind us.
Blue armor.
I'm just gonna make sure these guys...
Whoa.
Okay.
They have triple takes to get off the roof.
Yeah.
This is not gonna be a fun game for me.
Yep.
They're coming to us.
I'm gonna scan.
They're just chilling.
Oh, okay.
It's pretty far over there.
Yeah.
We're in the back off.
What the fuck?
Oh, bridge, bridge.
People.
Okay.
Bridge is fine.
They can hold that.
That bridge team is like... I'm like 99% sure they're gonna die.
Yeah.
Because everyone's gonna focus them.
Okay.
I'm just double checking there's extra resources.
I'm gonna hold here.
One team at the tree.
Bridge team is no longer at bridge from what I can see.
Okay.
Yeah.
They went below.
There's someone getting charge-rappled like crazy at tree.
Oh, there.
Here, here.
Okay.
Yeah.
In this truck.
So, Dito, you gotta watch that zip line because these guys can be here.
I'm looking behind us.
Oh, there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll be watching.
If someone gets close to you, just run straight for me.
I can smoke for you.
Okay.
We'll just give up that house if we have to.
But for now, just pretend like you're a full team there.
All right.
I'm a full team.
Don't come near me.
Yeah, they can hear this.
That works.
Don't come near me.
I'm standing on the roof because I'm so confident with my team.
One team that in the tunnel.
Oh, shit.
Maybe I shouldn't stand on the roof anymore.
Yeah.
I should.
I'm shooting tunnels so they know I'm here.
I'm getting longboard from fucking...
Oh, these guys dropped down.
Okay, they dropped down.
One guy dropped down.
Two of them, I think.
I think all of them dropped down.
Yeah, they're going for this building.
They're gonna hold that building.
I cannot see people behind me anymore.
Oh, no, they're over here.
Okay.
I need to save my heavy and just run through heavy.
There's people over where I pinged, northeast.
I'm gonna go and get them.
I'm gonna go and get back.
I have seen a lot.
Okay.
Are you okay?
Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm just poking them.
I'm just being annoying.
Just let everyone know we're here.
That's basically what we're doing now.
Yeah.
Like, make as much noise so people are afraid of, like, pushing this area.
And if we get evac, we just have to full fight for the spot.
We can't lose this spot.
So, if I get, like, pushed here, I need you guys to instantly, like, come and help make me here.
We do not want to give away these walls because they will be our one condition.
I'm so scared of rotating up here on the roof.
Just watch like in that direction just so no one's walking up from you there.
Oh.
What?
Oh my god.
I got shot by four people.
Okay, Deita, I'm gonna go for banner.
I got shot by so many people.
Okay, I'm gonna go away.
I got shot by two different teams.
I hate it here.
Really?
Guys, never...
Okay.
That's what happened to me.
I told you.
I'm gonna stop.
Res, res, res.
I told you.
Yeah.
They're pushing, they're pushing, they're pushing.
From where?
You get my... Oh.
Okay, I'm ulting that.
Okay.
She didn't get the res.
Yeah, I can smoke for you later.
Just stay alive.
What the fuck?
Every team is looking at us.
I will go on top and cover you.
Yeah.
Where do I land?
Go above.
Above probably is the best.
Cover.
I can't believe it.
Everybody's running sniper.
Yeah, it's just normal.
I can smoke your box later so you can take your shit.
Okay.
Did we lose this spot?
We didn't, right?
I don't see anyone here.
Oh, here I am.
I don't even know if I can... Yeah, I'll smoke your box later.
Okay.
I think I got these walls.
Yeah, yeah, I got... Oh, there's landing.
They're landing on the house.
One team landing.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, okay.
We can get that.
I'm well-kept out.
I'm not teaming up here.
Fuck this.
I'm gonna run sniper next game.
Yeah, I see him.
There's blue armor.
This guy's alone, I think.
One is B.
Yeah.
Dude, I can't... Like, I can't hit her because she's teleporting.
I'm gonna scan behind us.
Fuck, that's a loot box of juice.
That loot box is juice.
I want it.
Cover me.
No.
Uh... Okay.
Okay, okay.
Thank you.
I'll stay up here.
I'll stay up here, guys.
I'm just a little baby.
Holy shit, three bats.
I need ammo, ammo.
Heavy ammo.
I need sub 2.
There's no heavy ammo.
There's only light ammo.
Okay.
I have seven bats.
I can give bats.
Okay, yeah.
I know that.
I wanna cross ammo.
Can I cross ammo there?
I don't think you can, Dito.
You might die.
Maybe if I give you some.
Doki, Doki, three bats right here.
Yeah, I'll take it.
You need cells?
Here's four cells as well.
Yeah.
Wait, is someone zipping behind us?
Yeah, they are.
They're above.
They literally came up when I dropped down.
That's fucked up.
You have to play for me.
Oh my god, that's fucked up.
I literally got over here.
I got over here.
These guys are gonna get bullied by everyone, so it's fine.
How is he seeing?
Purple armor.
I'm so sad.
I literally got off just for the...
Literally, we gotta hyper focus that team.
For that loot box over there, is there attachments in that box or no?
Is there attachments in that box or no?
Yeah, like 301 attachments.
Oh, 301?
I can smoke it if you want.
Oh, no.
I'm fine.
Wait, is there a scope in there or no?
Probably.
Yeah, two times.
Yeah, I need it.
I need it.
Can you smoke it?
Alright.
Okay, we gotta only watch this team behind us.
This team literally has to push us or they die.
Or they have to go below.
So this team is like hyper priority right now.
They're getting Crypt ulted.
Okay, I got him.
Okay.
These guys got Crypt ulted.
What the fuck?
Why?
I think it's just to get griefed.
I don't know.
I'm running.
Purple armor.
I'm gonna run low and heavy again.
I can give you my heavy and I'm gonna swap to Carbine if you want that.
Actually, wait.
No, there's no light ammo in there.
Never mind.
There was 200.
Can you smoke the...
the replicator?
20 seconds.
We gotta keep looking this team behind us, guys.
Okay.
I'm looking.
I can scan the replicator, but I don't know if you wanna go or what.
Alright, you're gonna smoke it?
Smoke it.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
I smoked it if you wanna build ammo.
Up to you.
Do you wanna do it?
Keep looking at this.
What is that smoke?
What the fuck am I watching?
Okay, I'm gonna see if I can swap to Carbine then with Ditto.
Just make sure you craft ammo and then come back.
Both of you craft ammo.
There's a team in front of us!
I'm backing up.
I'm back.
I cracked one.
You're fine, you're fine.
Okay, just keep watching this team behind us.
I'm gonna...
smoke and I'm gonna ult them...
when they push.
I'm ulting now.
I'm standing behind us.
Just watch them.
Just literally watch them.
What about the team behind us?
That team behind us, yes.
Just watch them, the team above.
Okay, I'm looking.
I'm watching.
I keep beaming them.
There's a team in bridge shooting at us.
They're getting pushed by zone now.
Look, look, look.
I'm looking, I'm looking.
Purple armors.
They're banging with us.
I'm going to bloodhound.
I see them.
Scan them when you can.
Inside here is free.
Scan, scan, scan.
Okay, dodged.
I got hit by that?
Really?
Okay, I got hit.
I almost got beamed on.
Team on the left, team on the left looking at us too.
Just focus on this team only.
Focus on this team only in front of us.
They're still here.
I cracked them, I cracked them.
I cracked Horizon.
I got a bat.
This is not their crypto.
This is not their ult.
Yeah, I'm batting, I'm batting too.
I scan, I scan, I scan.
Just focus team in front.
Focus this team in front.
I'm focusing.
They're all cracked, bro.
Yeah.
Flash, flash, flash.
Oh, fuck.
My game.
All dead, all dead.
But another team behind us maybe.
My game all tabbed.
What?
One dead.
I got green.
My game all tabbed for some reason.
Did play on me, Ditto.
There's still more in front.
I'm so sad.
I got the heal, I got the heal.
I got the heal.
I told you.
Yeah, but it's...
Don't worry, Sneak.
Yeah, my game actually all tabbed.
Bullshit man.
Holy shit.
I'm shooting at a guy.
There's nothing happening to him.
Can you tell them to just swap?
Maybe swap servers.
I don't think it's a server thing.
I'm not sure.
Just stay alive.
Just play your life.
There's two guys in front of you, Ditto.
Yeah, just play your life, Ditto.
Just rat, just rat.
Yeah, just play below.
They're probably gonna fight each other.
You'll be free.
Yeah, there was a team true below us in the earlier so careful.
Okay.
Yeah.
Just play slow here.
Maybe you can go close to the truck.
I'll save that.
Later.
I like this spot's energy.
Let's go.
I think left side, all the way left side, if you walk with zone, you should be okay.
Left side?
Yeah, like there.
I don't know how I...
I don't know why it suddenly tabbed out.
It was crazy.
Maybe click the alt to the left?
Or maybe...
No, my game suddenly tabbed out of nowhere.
Yeah, that cliff maybe, Tito?
Is that in?
Right in front of you?
Yeah.
Oh, hey.
Maybe...
What about left side?
Right here.
Not in.
Yeah, she's not in.
She's also in zone now.
Play behind the truck.
Right there.
Oh, right side, right side.
Push the right side.
Nice.
Good kill.
Someone's in truck.
Just play behind the truck.
Just crouch behind the truck.
Yeah.
Seal their door.
Oh.
It's okay.
She's fine.
When you seal their door though...
Yeah.
Oh, no!
No, no.
You forgot to lock it.
What?
Unlock it.
No, you open.
No, they opened the door when you sealed it.
So you have to close it again.
They opened it before she stole it.
I see.
Only one guy.
Yeah.
No way.
That's one guy.
We got top five.
We're always top five.
Oh my god.
I'm fighting a Bloodhound.
And I'm shooting Havok at him.
And there's no numbers coming out of my house.
There's nothing.
Is it because you're streaming?
Maybe at this time when you're streaming and...
No, because it was happening off stream as well.
So I don't think it's a stream thing.
That's weird.
We're consistent, guys.
It's the pink corner because I didn't see the door open.
Yeah.
My stream is not dropping any frames.
It's not lagging.
Like, it's perfectly fine.
That's so weird.
By the way, I'm not sure if you can see it.
Discord is also perfectly fine.
Yeah.
It's just a game.
The game is just fucking lagging.
I don't know.
Maybe it's Apex.
Oh my god.
A person is getting beat.
Or maybe it's your VPN.
It's pretty much the same shit with our VPN.
It's just more pink.
You're shooting North America.
Not that line.
Yeah.
It's North America.
I am on North America.
Oh.
How was the first game?
First game?
First game was fine.
First game...
How about you change to Dallas again?
I can.
Yeah.
That's so weird.
I wonder why you're having these problems.
I don't know.
It might be my shitty ass stream.
Are you doing like...
Does it only happen during like our tournament thing?
Or was it...
Because it was okay.
No.
It was happening during my...
Like when I was playing ranked during stream, it was happening too.
At least I might won, I think.
Look at him.
Just focus on him.
Fucking bunny hopping.
Just shoot back.
Oh my God.
Moving.
Why is he just moving?
Maybe he didn't have reloaded.
Oh.
Is there 1v1?
This could be a 1v1.
Yeah.
I think this is a 1v1.
If they're not...
He's not getting pushed.
No.
It's 1v1.
They're not?
Why were they so scared?
Why was he so scared?
Let me try switching movement again.
Okay.
Guys,
yay!
Top 5!
Again!
We're consistent.
We keep getting top 5 with no kills because I can't kill anyone!
We got 4 kills!
Oh, did we?
Okay.
Yeah, we got 4 kills.
That's something!
But I could have killed both of those guys there if he wasn't just teleporting!
Shooting a whole hell clip and nothing comes out, dude.
It's so stupid.
Also, I think he needs to keep changing the code because I think the server gets laggy over time.
Oh, let him know that.
I don't think he has more codes.
I think he only has one.
Wait, this is a custom code?
I'm pretty sure this is literally just a random server code.
Yeah, it's a custom code.
Oh, from Apex?
Yeah, it starts with a P. Random server code starts with a C.
But why would he...
Does it matter?
Does it matter though?
If you get a code from EA, it's higher quality because it's a dedicated server.
Oh.
I see.
And I'm guessing he only got one code because...
Yeah.
15 minutes!
What am I gonna do for 15 minutes?
Oh yeah, there's a 15... because they're gonna interview the top five teams.
So we gotta chill for 15 minutes.
Why would you do it mid-turny?
Why would you do it after the turny?
Yeah, wait, why can't you just do it... you're right though.
This should be the end of the turn.
What the fuck?
Why are we mid-turny interviewing?
Like, what are...
They gotta pad it!
They gotta pad the tournament!
I think...
They better... okay.
That means... I guess like... they're not...
Did they lie?
Did they see me?
Yeah, yeah.
I mean... yeah.
They should.
They should be.
Oh shit.
Why would they interview me?
So I can tell them their server sucks?
Do it.
We're not top five.
We're not top five though.
We're top six.
Good.
Thank God.
No interview.
That's my plan.
Midway, the first three games, top six.
So they're gonna interview it.
And then you win the last three games.
Oh, haven't we won a game?
We don't lie.
Are you seriously asking that or...
I mean, you like...
RPR, why haven't we won a... I thought we're TSM.
I don't know, Doki.
It's kind of hard to win two or three, you know?
Like when someone... when Artemia dies on a roof, Artemia dies on a... on a wall.
It's like...
Wait, who died on the wall?
Who died on the wall?
Jesus Christ died reincarnated on the wall.
What do you think died on the wall?
I know it wasn't me.
You have selective memory?
Okay, stop the cat.
Selective memory looking ass.
I contributed.
Thank God we're exactly six, so no interview.
Yeah, we don't have to talk to people, but then you have to talk to me.
Fuck.
Yeah, which is better, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, yippee.
So much better.
It's like so much better.
Yeah, I think we should change our comp.
No.
Why?
We didn't get first.
I think you don't get a...
I don't think you get an input on comp.
But like we didn't get first though.
But both of you have lost your ability to put...
input anything about the comp.
Just gonna put that out there.
Both of you have lost that ability.
I no longer listen to you.
I am the captain.
Okay.
I found a mainstream.
I'm gonna change.
I'm gonna watch the main stream.
The main stream.
We're gonna check out the interviews.
I'm surprised they're interviewing five different teams.
That's like a lot of teams.
Why?
Shouldn't it be like three?
Cause like who cares?
Who cares when somebody is like top five?
Like rank four and five.
They should just interview you though, Ki-Ling.
Honestly, true.
They should just interview me.
I'm the most important.
Your stream needs to know what you said before.
You're so true.
You know what she said?
You know what she said before she started streaming?
Yeah, what did I say before?
She was like, Arpiel you shouldn't stream so I can get all the viewers.
And I was like, you don't have enough viewers.
And she was like, I want your viewers too.
No, no, no.
He's twisting the story.
Because he literally was like, I don't wanna stream.
That's what he said to us.
He was like, I don't wanna stream.
And I was like, oh I should.
Okay, then don't stream.
That's good.
So then I can keep all the viewers.
No, you said, I don't wanna stream.
You literally said, I don't wanna stream.
Stop lying.
I am not lying.
They don't record this conversation.
And you should like...
No, no, actually, actually.
I will say exactly what I said.
I said, do we have to stream?
And you said, you don't have to.
We have to stream.
Quote on quote, I don't wanna stream.
No, no.
No, that's it.
Quote on quote, I don't wanna stream.
No, it's not.
I said, do we have to stream?
With that intonation?
Okay, if I was like, do we have to stream?
If I said it with that intonation.
It's just a question.
Everyone will know that I don't wanna stream.
You said it with that intonation.
That's not how it works you guys.
Let me finish my sentence.
I said, do we have to stream?
Doki said, you don't have to if you don't want to.
I said, I'm gonna stream now.
But you don't have to.
And then I was like, why?
But I'm gonna stream.
And she's like, I want all the viewers.
I said, you have enough viewers.
She said, I want your viewers too.
Quote for quote.
Ditto, who's right?
Am I right or RP are right?
Do you wanna hear my answer RP?
Yeah.
You're gonna betray me again.
It's okay.
I'm asking.
It's okay because everything was recorded on Ditto's stream.
So whatever you say, everyone is gonna know that you guys are lying.
No, everyone would know I'm fucking right.
I've never lied in my fucking life.
That's true.
That's the first lie.
I'm the most honest man in this universe.
That's already the first lie.
Maybe in two universes.
You're not the most honest man in the universe.
What did I say?
You're more honest than fucking Jesus?
Yes.
I'm the reincarnation of Jesus Christ in Apex Legends.
Reincarnation of Jesus Christ who lives in Eastern Europe.
I've never lied in my life.
I would never fucking lie.
That's so fucking cap.
Ask me anything, I won't lie.
How much do you earn per month?
NBA.
NBA, I can tell you.
That's not an NBA.
That's literally not a lie.
I literally can't tell you.
Who the fuck you signed a contract with?
Yourself?
It's literally your own earnings overall.
My fucking esports org.
What do you mean?
You guys said overall.
That includes everything, not just your esports earnings.
Which also includes my salary, which I can't talk about.
Okay, minus your esports org.
Okay, how much do you earn per month?
How much do you... I asked the question first.
I don't know.
I never said I never lie.
Since it's that easy to answer that NBA question.
Okay, I'm a liar.
I'm a liar.
I can lie.
We all know you're a liar.
You're just proving my point.
Yeah, but I'm trying to prove my point.
That you said you never lie.
Then fucking tell the truth.
How much do you earn every month?
I'm not going to lose my job because of you.
Just minus your esports earnings.
With all your esports earnings, how much do you earn?
With my esports earnings?
I mean, what are they?
Like 150k or something?
Without your esports earnings?
For a month?
Without my esports earnings?
Yeah.
I don't fucking know.
Like...
Around 2k-ish?
I don't know.
2k-ish without esports?
And then 150k is overall?
We're talking about esports earnings.
My esports earnings...
I've earned 150k in my career.
No, I meant like with...
I meant your esports org.
I can't tell you that.
What do you want?
Minus your esports org.
What's your current salary per month?
Earnings.
I told you.
I literally told you.
2k?
I told you around.
Around 2k?
Without esports?
Yeah, because it depends on the month.
Oh, okay.
So on Twitch you earn 2k a month.
And other shit.
Wait, what's other shit?
Sponsors.
What are you asking me?
What kind?
I don't know when you get a sponsor.
Well now we know...
Look, Seekchat.
Now we know his Twitch earnings.
And sponsors.
You could have calculated yourself.
How could I?
You fucking said NDA.
Yeah.
You can see my sub count.
But you can't see my salary that's NDA'd.
You don't even have a sub count.
There's literally no sub count on your fucking stream.
I have your stream open.
It's under my stream.
Where?
Oh, there it is.
There's a sub goal.
Guys, I saw it.
It's public info.
Guys, it is public info.
He was right.
He doesn't lie.
Ditto, what question do you want to ask RPR?
Why do you only want to know about money?
You could have asked about anything.
And you focused on money.
You could have asked me anything in the world.
To be honest about it.
Then what do I ask you?
I don't know.
I ask you about money.
Are you a minhara?
I would say about 25% minhara.
And as this conversation keeps going, the number is increasing.
I mean, it's obvious he's a minhara.
I think you are the 100% minhara right now.
Like 100% minhara.
Right now.
No, I'm 25.
But if you keep talking, it's going to go up.
Do you like Doki?
What?
She's okay.
Do you like Doki?
Yeah.
Am I a good person?
Yeah, you're okay.
No, I asked you if you like Doki.
Am I a good person?
Not she's okay.
Yeah, I said yeah, she's okay.
Yeah, yeah.
She's going to get an ego.
She's going to get an ego from it.
No, I'm not.
No, because I already know.
I already know I'm amazing.
You're not the most narcissistic person I know.
Doki, I'm your best friend.
He is.
He's a minhara friend.
I'm literally not a friend.
He is.
He always talks about how he hates being here.
But every time I ask him to do a tournament, he says yes.
Yeah, yeah.
Because I bring in the content.
I gotta bring in the content for you.
Who's going to bring in the content?
I'm literally a content machine.
Content machine.
I'm a content machine.
What about Ditto?
Yeah, he...
Yeah.
When we play DT together, and when I ask him for money, he always sends me money.
Even if he told me that he didn't want to give me money.
Wait, really?
Can I have some money?
I don't send her money.
She's literally lying.
Can I have some money?
Ditto, you make like probably 10 times more than me.
Like what more do you want from me?
Like you give me money.
How about you give me some subs?
Wait, why are you asking us for money?
Why are you begging for us?
Because I mean it.
I literally need it.
I literally need money.
You make like 2k a month.
Don't talk about my salary.
2k is like an estimate.
Like some months it's lower, sometimes it's higher.
You know how Twitch works.
Yeah, but you also have your esports salary that you won't tell us.
So it's more.
Esports salary that may I add that I'm still not receiving because I haven't moved to Japan by the way.
Yeah, that's your own issue.
That's your own issue.
Now that's a visa issue.
That's true.
You can move at any...
Technically you can sort of start living there.
How would they know?
Ditto I think for all the content I create here you should give me some subs for real.
No, you should give us subs for giving you content.
You should give us subs for giving you content.
Because we're asking the hard questions here.
Like can we end this intermission?
I already had enough of you guys.
Can we get some primes in the chat for this bullshit?
Yeah, so you go to search my name up on Twitch.
DokiBird at Twitch.
And you can start a hype train over there.
You're so greedy.
How am I greedy?
You're literally greedy.
Like you're literally greedy.
Like you're the greediest person I know.
How am I greedy?
Did you see what you just did?
What did I do?
I just said can I get some primes in my chat.
You're like go to DokiBird Twitch and start a hype train there instead.
Like what is your problem?
I said instead.
Let other people eat too.
Holy shit.
Let us eat too.
I said if you want to it's your choice.
Let me eat too.
Woah RP.
Why are you so mad?
Relax bro.
If you're mad you can be IG of for the next match.
You have to calm down or you might lose your hair.
You're gonna start molding.
I have the most foolish head of hair on the planet.
Like I literally will never lose hair.
True.
I'm like I have so much fucking hair I could donate.
Do it.
I mean I'm gonna go to get a haircut on Monday so my donate everything gets off me.
Yeah.
I'm going for really short.
How many subs for you to shave your entire head?
I'm not gonna shave my head.
I did that before.
Oh so you don't want money.
He doesn't want money guys.
Listen I am an honorable man that draws a line and will not sell my soul.
He doesn't want money.
To get myself embarrassed on the internet.
Oh so what being bald is embarrassing?
For me yeah.
For me it is.
He doesn't like bald people guys.
He hates the bald.
I think some people look amazing bald.
I'm just not that guy.
You don't know that.
I don't look good bald.
All I'm saying is.
You've never been bald.
Right?
I have been bald before.
You don't know me my entire life.
You said you have a full head of hair and you'll never lose it.
Oh thank you.
Yes because I'm no longer cutting it all off.
I'm twitch.
You're insane.
This is insane.
This is not even a conversation.
Holy shit.
Bomb buying shot.
50 gifted.
Holy fuck.
Bomb buy.
Dude I think he is like 100%.
100%.
Oh my god.
Up here.
I think he's going crazy.
Sorry I got nuclear bombed in chat.
It was crazy.
Oh hey I have hype train.
Nuclear bomb buy.
I'm almost close to hype train too guys.
Holy fuck we got bomb buy.
Oh my god.
How do we survive?
It was a nuclear bomb.
I literally have...
Listen Doki I've had about 100 chatters today.
From your chat.
Come here and apologize in your stead.
That's not true.
They're like sorry that my orsh is the way she is.
Oh yeah?
In my chat I have people.
I never lie.
In my chat I have people coming in my chat being like.
Oh my god he's lost it.
He's crazy.
They're absolutely right.
I've lost the plot a long time ago.
I never lie.
You were like I would never apologize for Doki.
And up here in chat.
Always come to my steam and say.
It's up here fault.
It's okay it's up here fault.
This is just like a blast to me that was created years ago.
Oh hey.
15 minute intermission is done.
Our intermission is over.
The 15 minute torture is done.
Same comp?
Yeah.
They should call that shit 15 minute torture.
Oh my god thank you for the hype train everybody.
Thank you for the five gifted subs.
To the Doki bird twitch.
Really appreciate it.
Guys wait.
RPR what's your highest hype train?
Oh shit.
How do I know that?
I'm like maybe level 16 or something.
Level 16?
During my subathon.
Oh it was during your subathon.
Oh that makes sense.
Why don't we land?
I don't like honestly like.
My community like.
We don't have oilers and I'm fine with it.
I'm not really money.
I'm not a money hungry person in general.
As long as I have enough to survive.
Every month I'm chilling.
I don't really care about being a millionaire or being rich as fuck.
I just want to have fun.
Live.
Be alive.
Buy food.
Pay rent.
As long as I can pay your money for my car share.
Yeah.
Okay wait.
Wait a minute.
Dude that's less honorable.
As long as I can give this big corporation all my money that I earn with hard work every month.
As long as I can get cosmetics for a gig.
I'll be okay.
As long as I can give them all my money then.
I'll be good.
You know what?
She's right.
You can't judge her RPR.
You spend money on Apex.
I'm not judging.
I don't tell you.
You spend money.
Yeah but you had.
You did though.
But okay.
Hear me out.
I was making money off the game.
What Apex?
That's why I don't judge you.
By buying skins I was single handedly increasing my prize pool every tournament.
You understand?
So I was investing into my future by buying skins.
Think about that.
Think about that for a second.
That's stupid.
I did.
I thought about it.
That's stupid.
Why would you invest in the game when you can have other people invest in it?
Because at a certain time in my life I was actually naive and believed that this game was going in a good direction.
But you're still playing it.
And I regret all of my choices.
I'm only playing it because you invited me to this tournament.
Yeah but you were playing it yesterday.
Yeah because I was practicing for the tournament.
Yeah but you were playing before.
Because that's how I am.
I practice.
But you played before I invited you.
Because I had Apex Matsuri.
And I knew that I had to practice.
If you hate it so much why do you keep saying yes to Apex stuff?
Because the only good thing is like playing tournaments in this game.
Because the only fun thing in this game is tournaments.
Because you're having fun with us.
No.
But you're saying that's the only good thing.
Wait.
Stop gaslighting me.
Scan the zone.
Okay.
Oh I have to scan the zone.
I'm busy.
I scan the zone.
I will scan the zone.
Wait I want to crash though.
I need 2-0-1.
Wee.
Oh he is so tsundere.
I know guys.
Yeah he is tsundere.
I know.
He straight up was like...
He straight up said you only enjoy playing Apex in tournaments.
But then you're like not this one.
There's no exceptions.
Yeah because I'm lagging.
Yeah but you were lagging in the last tournament too.
No I wasn't.
I wasn't lagging in Apex.
Now you're just lagging.
I'm not talking about this last one.
I'm talking about the other last one.
Which I wasn't also lagging in.
There's a team in front of us.
Okay I will scan the lane.
I forgot.
Yeah.
Why are they here?
Can we kill them?
Yeah that's what I'm saying.
Who the fuck do you think they are?
They're in my fucking swamp.
I don't know where they are.
They disappeared.
They're in my fucking swamp.
I don't see them anymore though.
Are they hiding in the... They're in the bowl.
In the bowl?
When did they get there?
Oh my god.
Wait we killed these guys I think.
We have charge rifle.
I have the charge rifle.
I'm trying to find another sniper.
I can't find one.
Oh there's a longbow.
Okay nevermind.
I got it.
Cause I was like I'm tired of all these other snipers.
I want to snipe too.
The zone is not here.
Oh they're going left.
I think we killed them here.
They're going towards spiders.
Oh I hit him real hard with the fucking nade.
Look at this guy.
I'm terrible.
I'm actually terrible.
I'm coming over.
I need to be closer.
I'm terrible.
Don't talk to me.
I don't want to talk to you.
Oh that's the...
I stunned two right behind.
Okay I'm looking.
Horizon low.
Flash.
I got him.
Dead.
I'm trying to thirst him.
I'm going.
Thirst that motherfucker now.
I'm trying to.
I can't.
They got three on you.
Yeah I'm trying to destroy it.
Yeah I'm just...
They're all dead.
Oh my god.
Boba T lovers.
Oh no we did this to them.
Is that guy dead too on the left side?
Yeah they're all fucking dead.
He's here.
I see them.
They're on the right.
That's a spider.
Those are spiders.
Don't you have a sniper?
Like hello?
He was peeking behind the rock.
I have a sniper.
Sniper's not here.
Oh I need that.
Yeah.
Are we locating?
No?
Where do we go?
I'm killing these spiders for you.
Okay.
I'll go there.
These spiders have moves bro.
I can't hit them.
That's just sad.
Dude they're tap strafing.
What do you mean sad?
That's just sad.
Imagine losing to a spider.
Well I didn't take any damage so I'm not losing technically.
Imagine losing to...
In front of your entire chat.
Guys I would never miss a spider.
I'll miss a person.
Guys I'm getting bullied again.
I'd miss a person.
Guys but I would never miss...
Can we do something about this?
Do what?
About what?
About you.
I'm just having a conversation.
Just like how the other TSM have conversations.
I'm not allowed to have a conversation with my team now?
No they don't.
It's only working hard.
Ditto was I bullying?
No.
Yes.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Oh my god there's three bats here.
There's so much juice.
I need a backpack.
Yes.
I already have eight.
What is wrong with me?
I'm coming over.
Wait wait wait.
Are we getting shot?
Yeah yeah yeah.
Just come to me we're chilling here.
Bro why are they always fucking using triple take?
Why?
Wait.
The zone is not here.
Why they're here?
They're fucking stream sniping.
For what?
Okay I need that loot.
Everybody's using fucking triple take.
That's so weird.
I'm gonna grab that purple helmet though.
Yeah.
Get all that juice and then let's get schmoving.
Okay.
Wait they did have fucking...
They had everything.
Yeah they had everything.
They're so juiced.
What the fuck?
Someone's flying over you guys.
Oh they are.
Let's get schmoving.
I wanna rip this and I wanna rip this.
So that should give us purple.
Alright.
Oh I'm getting shot at.
Why the fuck are they shooting?
Hello?
They're mean.
They're so mean.
I think they might be... they're chasing.
They are?
I didn't even get a chance to grab the bats.
They look like they're chasing.
Yeah I'm coming over.
I cracked one.
I'm here.
I'm not here yet.
Bro fuck off.
I didn't even get a chance to...
These guys might jump in too.
I'll give you a... I'm dropping four.
I don't have them man.
Let's get moving.
I don't wanna get stuck in some stupid longbow dumbass fight across the planet.
Told you.
Everybody's using sniper now.
I told you.
Hold on.
I'm healing.
Let's hit this people beacon.
Okay.
And then let's hit the ring console.
And then we should have purple right?
I'm like very close to purple.
You're right Leek.
Yeah.
I'm like 50 of purple.
Oh no.
Where was my body block?
Guys I think we're fucked.
Bloodhound's low.
We're getting turrets in our back.
I think you guys should go.
Just leave.
Why me?
I cracked one.
Guys I don't...
Guys I don't wanna play bloodhound anymore.
Wait where was my smoke RPR?
I didn't think we needed it.
I gotta take this.
Goodbye.
Okay.
They didn't finish you so we can maybe rez you.
Yeah I'm gonna hide behind you.
I'm trying.
That's not a team.
Are they evacing towards me?
Please I will murder all three of you.
Come.
Come right now.
I'll fucking handle all three of you guys.
I can take three guys.
Are they still there?
Yeah they're evacing away.
We can rez.
Can you rez?
Yeah yes.
Hello.
Hello everybody.
Guys.
I don't like bloodhound anymore.
Just heal up.
Guys I don't wanna play blood.
I fucked up.
I fucked up the heals.
I thought I had time to medkit.
I'm gonna heal you with the smoke.
I thought I had time with the medkit.
I timed it incorrectly.
We're going to scan the zone after you've done that.
Okay.
I don't have much...
I have one medkit as well.
Okay.
And then I'm gonna...
I have a re-replier too.
Why there was...
There was two party here.
I don't know.
Here we go again.
Alright somebody...
What the fuck am I looking at right now?
We gotta go cause I only have one medkit.
We gotta get the fuck out of here.
Get out of dodge.
Okay I need a syringe.
Okay I'm gonna cough here.
Do I have time?
I think I might die while I'm re-repliering.
I'm actually dead cause I have no syringes.
I have a medkit but I don't know if I have time to pop it.
I'm dead.
I need to get res.
Well I need a medkit.
Ditto do you have syringe?
Ditto I need one syringe.
Yes.
Are you resing?
Okay you're resing.
Okay I'm gonna back run then.
I need one syringe or I can't heal.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay I might be dead again.
Okay.
What the fuck they're camping.
They're camping.
Full team they're pushing up.
They're pushing up right now.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
It's a full team.
Do you have evac Ditto?
I had evac though.
We're like crouching outside too.
We have no choice.
Oh my god.
I got fucking griefed so hard.
I had no meds left.
I think.
I'm not sure.
I have read the play.
You have to get... there's a callus spike in front of you.
So...
This is what it is.
We have no choice but to run through it.
You guys have mobile respawn though.
Yeah but these guys are gonna be our biggest problem.
Yeah we have a wall.
We have a wall.
Perfecto.
Let's go that way.
Oh my god.
I almost saw my ult.
Did you guys get my read the play?
I don't know.
I didn't get it.
Come with me.
I get my ult.
I'm gonna ult left side.
2%.
1%.
Oh there's a guy up the rock.
There's a guy up the rock.
I just saw him.
This guy from the left is annoying.
This is my ult.
I'm probably dead.
Yeah you're dead.
No audio.
What is wrong with people?
Why are you guys playing like this?
Guys we shouldn't play edge.
We weren't edging there.
We were going zone.
But everyone else was for some reason rotating towards us out of zone.
Because we don't know how to rotate.
So they rotated into us.
How does that make sense?
Did we want to swap?
I don't want to play blood out anyway.
I'm getting bullied on blood out.
They don't know where they're going.
So they're just running randomly I guess.
What the fuck is going on?
I think maybe we can play like casual.
Like kill everyone that we see.
Yeah maybe we have to just murder people.
I think so too.
We can fight.
We can rotate because we will do stupid shit.
So we just have to fight everyone.
Fight the whole server.
Might as well.
I mean we have to get kill points now at this point.
Yes.
Yeah we're just getting like capped.
I got fucking capped out.
I literally saw a guy fucking hugging the wall.
Like two teams came to us outside the zone.
I don't know why.
Two teams came to barometer behind us.
Barometer was nowhere.
It was nowhere near the zone.
And then sandwiched us with two more teams that were in prowler nest.
So we got sandwiched by four teams that were not in the zone.
And not moving towards zone.
This isn't a JP tournament.
This is an NAU tournament.
Yeah I forgot.
There's no brain cells here.
Nobody rotates.
You gotta remember.
Just fight everyone.
Just get good loot and fight everyone.
There's too many control players in this lobby for there to be any IQ involved.
So we have to fight.
We start fighting next game.
We have to just full fight everyone.
Wait are you still lagging though?
I feel like I'm lagging but like I'm just ignoring it mentally.
You choose if you believe there's no lagging.
Maybe there isn't.
There's nothing I can do about it so I'll just ignore it.
Yeah.
Alright now I'm gonna...
The fact that we even raised you there was only for the fact that there were so many teams there that they couldn't finish you.
Thank fucking god.
See everybody's fighting.
Nobody's playing zone.
There's a fight to our left as well.
They're freaks man.
These guys think they're playing pubs.
We're just gonna run around and hit all the beacons in the world until we have like purple red and we're just gonna fight the first team we see.
Look at that!
There's only four teams there fighting!
What the fuck am I looking at?
Why can't we do that?
I don't know.
Why can't that be us?
Maybe stop dying?
Oh okay.
Hey Doki, scan the ring.
Okay, no smoke.
That's fine.
You can't blame me for that.
Why is there four teams in Prowler Nest?
Why are they there?
What are they looking for?
The fucking hidden treasure from Captain Morgan?
You can't blame it on me!
You called me to scan!
I listened.
I was listening.
But the other game you sit on a roof and three teams beat you up at the same time.
Oh yeah yeah yeah.
Hey Doki, do the peek.
The people scan.
Okay, let me do the people scan.
As there was no smoke and my...
And my Bangalore was looking away from me while I get shot at.
Oh okay, yeah it's my fault.
First game!
I didn't die first.
First game, you both died.
You can't gaslight your way out of this.
There are certain situations that you can't gaslight your way out of.
And this is one of them.
Yes I can.
Chat, who's right?
Me or Imperial RPR?
Of course Imperial RPR is always right.
It's always reps and heaven's fault.
You don't fucking know this.
Guys, who's right?
Guys, Imperial RPR?
It's fucking...
Oh my god, look how many RPRs in your chat.
Wow!
Wow Doki!
Even your viewers know you're lying.
And you're like, They're saying Dito more than Doki.
Yeah, cause Dito's on my side.
Their hosts and their devs are always together.
No.
Dito, are you on my side?
Yes.
No.
See?
Oh!
Yeah, Dito and Doki vote together.
Why am I 2v1?
I'm not gonna IGL anymore.
You guys IGL'd them.
Imperial HAL is able to get 2v1.
No.
Imperial HAL 1v2s.
There's a difference.
You're just the...
What can I say?
The poor man's Imperial.
You guys are poor man's Repson Eve Evan.
Like, what the fuck is going on?
No, we're the better version of Repson for hosts cause we're anime girls.
We're the better version cause we're anime girls.
On the discount section.
Anime girls are out of meta.
That shit's so 2022.
Like, we're out of that meta.
What's the current meta, huh?
Funny people on Twitch.
Like how you had to specify on Twitch.
Like twitch .tv slash RPRX or twitch.tv jinxy or twitch.tv twitch.tv the sketch reel.
Like, funny people.
Not anime girls.
Anime girls are out of meta.
Bro, this man's fucking coping.
No, no, I'm telling you this is the meta.
Like, I follow the meta.
Okay, I play Bloodhound.
Yeah, you're Bloodhound now.
You're Catalyst.
Oh, Jesus Maria, someone help us.
Yay, I'm Catalyst!
Is there one more?
Is there two more games?
Two more games, right?
Yeah, two more games.
Two more games.
And we're just running at people, right?
We're just running at people.
I mean, I feel like at this point, like, everyone's fucking fighting anyway, like, we might as well join the fucking hate fest that's going on.
So we can at least get kill points and loot.
Like, why be smart when you can be dumb?
Like, that's my motto in life.
Yeah, because we're the better dumb players.
Like, why put your effort in being smart when you should be dumb?
Like you?
I mean, to be fair, that's you on default, though.
You're right.
Like, you literally half an hour ago admitted that you are not smart.
You said, I'm dumb.
Yeah, but like, I have smart moments.
Do you?
Okay, I had smart moments in my life too.
Like, I won ALGS.
Do you?
Like, that was smart.
That was pretty smart.
Yeah, but that was two years ago.
Okay, and I do smart things every now and then.
But like, I don't need to be smart anymore.
Like, I can be dumb.
I'm in a position where I can be dumb.
So why would I put effort in being smart?
I can just be dumb.
To win the tournament?
To win easier.
Who the fuck cares?
I'm like, 25% Menhera, 25% dumb, 50% don't care.
This is the life I lead.
Holy shit, the first place team is 79 points.
That's crazy.
Yeah, I mean, the balancing is just out of this world.
The balance is just out of...
We just blame it on balancing and we're good.
That team doesn't have a pro player.
The balancing is crazy.
That team doesn't even have a pro player.
In what way?
They probably have three controllers.
They probably got three controllers.
Therefore, 0.4...
That's 40% of all their efforts is controlled by an AI.
All of them are MNK.
40% of their... That's bullshit.
There's no way all of them are MNK.
Absolutely not possible.
You don't know this.
You're just gaslighting.
No, I'm speaking... Where's Kalos?
Okay, there.
You don't even know where Kalos...
I have Kalos in like a fucking...
two plus months.
Oh my god.
My cable's stuck on the chair!
What?
What happened?
I watched your stream.
She's going through a lot right now.
Almost lost my... almost my head.
Almost run over my head.
She's going through a lot.
And whose fault is it?
Not me.
The first... the first players team, they have good ping.
That's the reason.
That too.
That is also...
That is a valid factor.
I literally asked you, Isidore, are you okay with playing on NA ping?
And you said yes.
Our good ping players not doing shit.
You said...
You said we're gonna destroy the tournament.
I was like, are you okay with playing on NA ping?
And you're like, yes.
Okay, well, but unforeseen circumstances happened.
One, I'm lagging like a bitch.
Unforeseen circumstances.
Two, what is this balancing?
Like, what the fuck?
We have three pred players on one team.
You're telling me that's okay?
What?
For which one?
Which team?
The first team.
First place team is not three pred players.
It's like two master players.
Who are they?
Do you know them?
It's Kaisa and Hachi.
Stop the cap!
You're telling me Kaisa and Hachi are dropping 79 points?
Yeah, they are.
Who's their third?
I don't know.
Seroku or some shit.
I don't fucking know who that guy is.
That's literally a team of masters.
Our team is literally three pred players.
Okay, bro.
And we're like ninth place.
Three pred players.
Stop the cap.
None of us have gotten pred in like four years.
Calm down.
Yeah, but the first place team never touched pred.
Okay, but like, touching pred means nothing in this game.
Yeah, and they've never...
they've been masters.
We've all been masters.
Why are we not first?
We might not have touched pred a long time, but we've all been masters.
I was literally masters like a couple of months ago.
You're probably gonna go kill everyone.
Why are you not killing anyone?
Why aren't you not...
Why aren't you killing everyone?
I'm killing people!
You're not finishing them.
I'm the one with the most issues here and you give me the most shit.
I literally have people teleporting like what do you want from me?
That's your issue.
Yeah, so fucking help me out and kill someone.
We do.
We knock people.
You don't finish them for us.
What am I supposed to trade my life away for a finish?
Yeah, cause then at least we get kill points.
Yeah, and we die.
You get one kill point and you die and think that's how you play tournaments?
That's better than zero kill points.
I just can't handle you.
There's no way you're serious.
You're not even serious about this tournament.
What do you mean?
I was so serious.
I'm like literally the only one that's taking this seriously.
Shut the fuck up.
Me and Ditto are both taking this so seriously.
Yeah, I'm not taking it.
I'm the one that's not taking it seriously.
You told me to scan the people speaking without a smoke.
You didn't even smoke for me.
Okay, but who can predict four teams to be here when the zone is here?
Yeah, but a good IGL would smoke in advance.
A good IGL would predict that.
Yeah, okay.
Let me go out of zero.
Zero would be a good idea.
I don't know what I told Jen to smoke for Sykes.
Wait, what should I do?
Spikes or Veil?
Increase ultimate length or increase max?
Always ult.
Every ult.
Ultimate length and ultimate duration.
Okay, I'm ready to go whenever.
Yeah.
We're running at people, right?
Let's fight.
Yeah, but we first want to get purple.
We don't want to fight with shitty fucking Walmart armor.
How do we get purple?
Okay.
I'm doing literally spiders right now.
I will scan the enemy.
We're gonna scan every single beacon until we have purple.
I'm taking the redeploy to you.
We're gonna go here next.
Taking the cannon to you.
Hello.
Oh my god, I'm juicing the spiders.
You're doing so well.
I'm juicing the spiders.
The spiders will juice the gold mags and purple stocks and shit.
Like what the fuck?
We're rich.
But that's crazy.
There's people in the...
Okay, there's people in the...
We want to go here so we can hit two more scans.
Oh my god, stop teleporting, stupid game.
We don't have Ditto with us.
Yeah, we're gonna shoot them.
We're gonna kill them.
We're gonna murder them.
Ditto's far.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's fine.
We're gonna wait for her here.
Okay.
I have one bat only.
Do you guys have all the bats?
I have a bat here.
I have two.
Be careful, be careful.
Ditto, hurry up.
Let's go.
Yeah.
She's so far.
We need to be fast and swift.
Can this team scan this from far away?
I'm gonna play from the door here to see if there's teams still here or not.
Are they still there?
I don't see anyone.
But they could be ratting, I guess.
The minespeed is fine.
We wanna hit this beacon, Ditto.
And then when the ring closes, we wanna hit the ring console again.
Okay.
And then that should give us purple, I think.
We can't fight.
I can't see anybody.
I'm scared.
Yeah, I think they finally rotated to the zone.
Great job, guys.
Wow!
Wow, we moved!
Well, I need that.
I should probably...
Why is that door juiced up?
I don't like that.
Should we scan?
Yeah, scan them, Ditto.
Okay, good, good, good.
Come here and hit the juicer.
Okay.
Yeah, you should smoke here.
Yeah, where's the smoke?
I smoked it!
Oh, there's a car behind us.
What the fuck?
Oh, look at these guys riding!
Look at them riding!
What the fuck?
I thought you said there's a car there.
Oh, there's one team here, one team here too.
Team here, yeah.
Yeah, I'm coming over here.
My bullets are not registering.
They are not registering.
I repeat.
There's so many teams!
Come to me, play on me.
Oh, no.
I'm fucking... Bangalore?
Yeah.
I'm at the hill.
That guy's playing juiced Sentinel.
It's not fair!
What is that shit?
They're running back.
Let's go to the tunnel while we can.
I don't want to get stuck here between four fucking teams.
Again.
Yay!
I won bad now.
I'm so sad.
Are we not doing the map scan?
No, because they're there and I don't want to die fucking doing it.
Smoke me.
Yeah, and what did they just decide?
Oh, let's go back.
For no reason at all.
They would never.
No way.
Listen, we need to adapt to the IQ in the lobby.
Which is not very high.
Okay?
Okay, guys.
I'm going to tell this a while.
How many spikes can I have up at one?
Two.
Doors is three, right?
Is doors three?
Doors is two.
Didn't used to be three?
I guess they took it away.
I don't think so.
Oh, wait.
Someone smoked it.
They're juicing it.
Blue armor.
Can people stop teleporting?
I'm actually going to have a moment with myself.
Are they just going to...
Can you scan the building?
Are they just going to sit there?
Like we want the bacon.
We want the bacon.
Where are you guys... Where are they going?
Oh, what?
Okay.
That's the motherfuckers with the sentry.
Are we going to start a fight?
I want to, yeah.
Alright.
They scanned.
The people scanned.
Twelve seconds.
I'm fucking... I'm ulting them.
Oh, they're trying to settle.
We need to get close so the sentry is useless.
Wait, another team.
Another team.
I'm getting beamed around corners.
Okay, we can't fight this anymore.
Yeah, yeah.
That's so annoying.
What the fuck?
Are they trying to pull off damage?
Go here.
Alright.
I'm heading over.
Head to HPR.
I'm going to... I literally might have to craft a bat here.
Yeah, I have one bat left too.
We're getting like, thirded so fast too.
Oh, they're fighting.
I hear them fighting like behind us from the spiders.
Maybe we can third that.
Okay, I'm going to craft a bat as well.
Yeah, craft a bat.
He used... He used... He used...
I got it.
They're fighting behind us?
Right?
No, no.
Yeah, I think they're fighting on this house this here.
Also, Ditto, I have an ulti-excel.
Do you want it?
Oh, yeah.
I want it.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm good.
Whoa.
Did someone fly to us?
Fucking sentinel guy is here.
Someone fly to us.
Okay.
Ditto, we're not with us.
You're not with us.
Ditto, Ditto.
Ditto, you're not with us.
Can you wall me?
Wall, wall, wall me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll smoke you.
Oh, I already walled it.
I heard wall and then I walled.
Okay, that's been nice.
Almost killed that guy.
Almost killed Watson.
Dude, I kind of want to like kill these guys.
They're just mirroring us the entire time.
Like, fuck off.
Is that a sentinel team?
Yeah, it's a sentinel team.
Can you scan this building?
Uh-huh.
Yeah, they're just there.
I just got three norex.
Nice.
Love the game.
Can I see them?
Not a norex.
Nice.
Are they in there?
Yeah, they're in here.
Second floor.
Almost cracked another one.
Should I push up or no?
Five seconds to scan.
Cracked Watson.
Like, these guys are getting beamed up.
I'm pushing up.
Climb up here, yeah.
I took the door.
I'm pushing up.
I think we actually have to go zone because it's so far from me.
It's only a minute.
I'm smoking you and come back to me.
I might be dead.
I'm dead.
I'm dead from this.
I'm alive.
You're alive.
Heal up.
Down here.
I'm batting.
They're looking for her.
One guy second floor, two guys below.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna reinforce.
I'm medicating.
Look for her, Dita.
They're down here.
Okay, I will scan after batting.
We have 44 seconds.
Cracked one.
Almost cracked two.
Can you scan?
These guys are suicidal.
Let's go.
Okay.
Leave or...
Oh, okay.
Leave.
No, no, no.
Come, come, come.
Come with me.
We leave them and we gatekeep them.
There's only thing we can do.
I got shot.
You good, Dita?
Yeah, I'm good.
I have... We have redeploy that we can use.
I'm redeploying here to get ahead of them.
Okay.
They have all of us.
Be careful.
Land on these spiders and gatekeep these guys.
Okay.
Oh, they're going left.
Fuck.
Fuck, pussies.
Should we kill the spiders?
Yeah, we do spiders for Eva.
Yeah, that's interesting.
Even the spiders are fucking...
Wait, what?
There's a squad from command center.
Command center.
Oh, okay.
Keep watching the command center team.
Okay, like...
Suck a dick?
Should we go behind us?
No, right?
Double checking.
They could walk up behind us, but I don't...
Okay, this guy's shooting smoke.
He's cheating.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Awesome.
Why do we get... I got a limax.
If you guys want, for some reason?
Yeah, I need it.
We got zones still.
Like, we're still chilling in zone.
Okay.
Two bad still cells.
One bad steak cell.
One bat.
Oh, wait.
13 shield cells.
If anyone needs shield cells.
I hate this.
Give some to Dita.
I gave three.
I'm watching left side here.
We can maybe trip out of here.
Oh, look at this guy.
One HP on a Watson.
Oh, I'm coming back.
That's the Watson team in there.
Someone's rezzing there.
I kind of want to get close here and grieve this team.
Okay.
I'm pushing up.
One.
Let's fuck them up.
Let's get the building.
I can put a wall.
I don't think we need it.
Okay.
Oh, he's on the fucking door.
But I'm good.
I'm good.
I'm gonna destoy the door.
I'm gonna take their door actually.
I got a bat.
I'm gonna get on the window.
I took the door.
That's theirs.
They're on the stairs.
They're vanguarded.
They have a JN on the left stair.
I can get rid of the door whenever.
Wait, wait, wait.
You're okay?
Who's shooting you?
New team or?
No, no.
The same team.
They're coming to me.
I'm looking for you.
They're not.
They're beaming me around the fucking whole corner apparently.
They're coming.
Oh.
What the fuck is that?
I might need help.
Kill this guy.
He's alone.
How can he know?
I got it.
Yeah.
I died around the whole corner.
That was bullshit.
What am I supposed to do there?
I think this is your team.
I'm fucking fucking cornered.
Oh, no.
This is Linkzer's team.
I see.
Fucking 200 ping Andy.
Of course I'm on the corner.
Wait, but Linkzer's also EU.
Yeah.
It's double ping.
You guys could run corners even more.
On his skin, I was probably still on the building.
I was really way back.
But why didn't you both cancel each other out?
Yeah, it's double ping.
I have 200.
He has 200.
It's like 400 minus that.
It's crazy.
It's crazy, dude.
It's double ping.
It's crazy.
Oh, they're dead.
Yeah, Karma.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
He afterhasted.
Yeah, get fucked.
Holy shit.
He got me through the cold blood.
They're being so hard.
By the way, the team in the first place you said is Hachi and Kaisa.
You're lying out of your ass.
It's 0-0.
No, it is.
No, it's 0-0.
No, it's numbnuts.
What are you...
It's 0-0.
Oh yeah, it is.
Who are they?
I don't know.
0-0 and Jaycee.
I don't know who these people are.
0-0 is a literal active pro.
You're just straight lying.
We're just lying now.
You didn't fact check me.
I just fact checked you.
It took you like so long.
They're literally three pregs.
Like you're on some shit.
They're actually 19th place.
Yeah, I know.
I just saw.
I'm like, dude, Kaisa and Hachi are destroying this lobby.
You're just straight lying out of your ass.
I wasn't lying.
I read it wrong.
Read it wrong?
What did you turn the leaderboard upside down?
What happened?
I told you I'm not that smart.
You're the one that didn't fact check the dumb person.
No, you're right.
I should never trust my teammates.
You're right.
You're the IGL.
You should think for yourself.
Yeah, you're right.
This is my mistake.
It is.
It is my mistake to ever trust you in anything.
As the IGL, you should know I was wrong.
That you're a liar.
Yeah.
I got it.
I mean, I admitted it right off the bat.
I mean, yeah.
But still.
The fact that you continue to trust me after I said I'm a liar.
It's really your fault.
I might as well have you on mute.
Because you're lying the entire time.
No, because I tell you when people are there.
You can't mute me.
Nah, I think I'm good.
You might be even lying about that shit.
Who knows?
You're not having fun, though?
Aren't you having fun?
Yeah, it's great fun.
Wow.
So much fun.
Right, Ditto?
Yeah.
That was the worst yeah I ever heard in my life.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm having the best time of my life, friends.
I can trust you.
I can trust her, dude.
I can.
How many people are in the same team?
FUDA and Zero Nothing play on the same ALGS team.
Last call?
I'll say that again.
FUDA and Zero Nothing the members of the first place team are playing in the same ALGS team.
Yeah, but anybody can sign up for ALGS.
The teammates in ALGS.
Anybody can sign up for ALGS.
Zero Nothing has been playing pro for five years.
Yeah, but he's never made it.
What do you mean he's never made it?
He's been on G2 and like many other orgs.
What are you on about?
Yeah, but I don't know who he is so he's never made it.
Oh my god.
You're such a narcissist.
It's insane.
She thinks the world revolves around her.
Thank you.
25 kills.
They have 25 kills.
Yeah, bro.
They're playing ALGS against a couple of VTubers.
That's what I'm saying.
This is not a VTuber tournament.
Because there's not enough VTubers.
There's not enough VTubers to make a VTuber tournament.
I'm flaming them.
This is my reality.
If I don't know who they are they never made it.
I told them to pack their bags.
They're done.
They're done for the day.
Wait, how did they get into a VTuber tournament?
Wait a minute.
That's actually a good question.
How did they get into a VTuber tournament?
Because I don't understand the other pro players because they know VTubers.
Wait, which VTuber do they know?
I don't think they have a VTuber on their team.
Wait, what?
Why are they here?
Wait.
I would assume they would have at least one.
One VTuber.
They're literally playing ALGS and we're here in kindergarten.
Wait, people are actually saying they don't have one?
Wait, what the fuck?
They don't even have a VTuber on their team?
No, they don't.
They actually don't?
Isn't this a VTuber tournament?
No?
By name.
It's supposed to be a VTuber tournament.
No.
We're over here playing in kindergarten league and they're playing ALGS.
This is not fair.
Their 3D model is just that insane.
Guys, you don't understand guys.
To be fair, there's not enough NA Apex VTubers or EU Apex VTubers to be fair.
Type 1 in chat to kick nominates out of the tournament.
Everyone's typing 1.
Alright, pack your bags.
To be fair, they're all from EU and you know how bad EU prize is.
You don't make money in EU.
They need this.
I mean, in my...
Is that bad?
EU is pretty bad when it comes to prize pools.
You know that.
How many points do they get?
Bro, they got 25 kills, man.
I think they've had multiple 20 kill games in this lobby.
I mean, they're running at people who don't even play this game.
Not don't play, but obviously not that much.
I mean, they're at level.
So it's very easy for them to run.
Yeah, but I'm saying it's so fucking unbalanced.
No one can say anything.
We have ALGS team in first place and then everyone else.
They have like 100 points already.
What are we playing?
For a second.
We're here for a second place.
What did I sign up for?
I think even if we killed everyone in the lobby and won the game and respawn farm them, we can't catch up to them.
We need to go on like a...
We need to respawn farm every single team once in this lobby and we still wouldn't catch up to them.
Wait, even with respawn farm, what if we all work together with the other teams and just respawn farm them?
That's what I said.
Kick them out the tournament.
Yeah, but they're still going to be first place no matter what.
Delete the VODs!
Delete their points!
Move along!
I'd deal with them quick then.
Second place is first place now guys.
Yeah, first place no bread.
Second place all bread.
And also wherever we land should be like an extra prize pool.
Guys, just start the game.
Guys, I don't care!
Just let me leave!
Guys, if they're trying to fix what to do with the first place team, I don't care.
GG go next.
I just started so much drama bro.
I don't care!
Bro, it's literally the first place was literally $125!
I just started so much drama I'm just going to sit here and laugh.
I only got an Akasupa to just like in the beginning of the stream.
I already made more than the tournament.
Just go!
I just started this part.
I just started this part and I'm just going to relax and watch it unfold before my eyes.
This is the best entertainment.
Akasupa, what did you do?
This is so good.
You're going to be late to your fucking other stream.
We're ahead of schedule!
This is karma.
This is karma for your gaslighting.
No matter what I said I was going to leave exactly at 3.
It doesn't matter.
I would leave in the middle of the game if I have to.
This is karma.
My Minhera activated.
I'm starting drama, bro.
Next is the Linksr.
Linksr!
Dude, Linksr next!
He's a current pro!
Where's your VTuber?
Start kicking motherfuckers at the lobby!
Kick all the 3D models out!
I'm starting shit now!
He is in his Minhera mode.
Oh, you don't have a VTuber?
Oh!
Oh my god.
I'll be out.
You don't have a VTuber model?
You're out!
No VTuber model.
No play.
Ken said I gotta go.
He called me KN.
Holy shit.
AHHHH!
Why aren't we I... I... Wait.
Why aren't we starting?
I'm so confused.
Why?
I actually don't know.
I actually think...
I might have started some shit.
Did you... Maybe like people are yelling...
Bro!
What if people are raiding the poor organizer stream?
I mean...
Wait.
If you're going on the organizer stream and talking shit, I do not claim you.
Stop talking shit.
I actually do not do that.
Don't be weird.
It's all fucking memes.
We'll only talk shit behind the scenes.
Yeah.
Don't talk shit to their face, bro.
Do it, Bob.
Yeah.
RPR is teaching us a lesson right now.
Talk shit behind their backs.
Is that right, RPR?
Is that right?
That's what you said, not me!
I literally reiterated what you just said!
I just rephrased it.
I said don't go in their chat and talk shit.
You said don't go in their chat and talk shit in their face.
Yeah, but you were talking shit behind their backs this entire time.
It's called a joke!
Yeah, sure.
A joke.
You lost your humor?
Like you don't know what jokes are anymore?
Like what happened?
But you didn't say it on sarcasm!
Do I have to say slash s at the end of every sentence?
Like what is this, Twitter?
Yes.
I'm a little special.
I can't read people's sarcasm.
Trust me, we know you're special.
I'm a little bit.
I think...
Wait, what do you think?
What do you think?
What does that mean?
No, nothing.
Let's go lend.
On our lending spot.
Yeah.
Ditto, you're a jump master.
Okay.
So far.
So I say we just fucking...
I don't fucking... let's just kill everyone.
And if we kill them, we kill them, they die.
You said we were going to kill everybody, but we didn't kill everybody.
We kept running away.
We ran into the first place team!
What do you want from me?
You got three breads and two poor pro players.
What can I do?
I did a thousand damage, we still didn't kill anyone.
What more can I do?
Two thousand damage.
If I had controller, I'd 1v3.
Plug it in, you literally have your roiler next to you.
I can't do that.
I can't play tournament controllers.
That's so beneath me, it's insane.
I would lose all my fucking achievements I've ever made in like five seconds for plugging in controller during tournament.
People love roller players.
Look at Jen Burton.
Someone in my chat said, is TSM playing?
We're literally TSM.
Yeah, we're literally TSM.
TSM is in this tournament, guys.
Guys, we're in a tournament with TSM, chat.
We are TSM.
What do you mean with TSM?
Yeah, we got signed.
We literally got signed.
We are TSM.
Gotta say, this version of TSM kinda sucks ass.
Yeah, but you're the IGL, so it is your fault.
That's not how things work in life.
You can't just blame everything on the game leader.
Yes, you can.
That's the whole point of having an NG leader.
You have to reflect on your own actions sometimes.
Yeah, but my NG leader doesn't teach me well.
Well, teach you what?
You're unteachable.
I'm not.
I won first place in the Tekken tournament.
And I was taught to be better.
Okay, it's not Apex Legends.
Nope, but it's competitive.
Sure.
Are you trying to say fighting games are not competitive?
No, I think Street Fighter is competitive.
Yeah, okay.
What about Tekken?
Yeah, yeah.
You don't think Tekken is competitive?
That's fucked up.
Guys, he doesn't think Tekken is competitive.
I think whatever game you play is just not competitive.
So I play Apex.
Exactly.
So Apex is not competitive.
So your achievements don't count because Apex isn't competitive.
No, when I played it was competitive.
Now it's just us.
That's how things work out.
You think this game is competitive?
Like this game is the most RNG bullshit on the planet.
Like it's probably the least competitive.
It's a BR.
When you used to play it, when you used to play it, it was even more RNG than before.
No, no, no.
It was less RNG because there was no aim assist involved.
You actually took skill to shoot people.
Okay, we have to go gap.
Okay.
Oh my god, we got zone.
I'm gonna cry.
Yeah.
I don't want zone.
I thought we were gonna run at people.
What happened?
We can't run at people if you have zone.
Like why do we keep giving a zone?
No!
What is wrong with them?
I don't want to be in zone.
It's scary.
I need...
Any game that allows an AI computer to aim for you is not a competitive game.
Maybe you're just...
In a mixed input environment.
Just shoot better than a controller player.
Just use your movement.
I mean if I install aimbot, I got that.
Why do you say ditto?
I'm gonna go gap though.
Okay.
I'll cover you.
I need to open this red bin.
There's people over there on the left.
Already?
People are shooting already.
Wait, people are shooting.
People are literally shooting each other and going to zone now.
There's a fight here.
Let's go up top.
I mean, oh my god, this is so sad.
We don't get loot.
We don't get evos.
They just cucked us.
Why do we get zone?
Because they hate us.
I hate getting zone.
They hate us.
So stupid.
We can do anything with this.
We got zone like three times out of six games.
I think Kuro is literally just grieving us on purpose.
Like he's placing these zones around our fucking forehead.
They're fighting kinda.
Which way?
They're not gonna fight.
They were fighting earlier.
I saw them.
It's this team and this team.
They're smoking and like poking.
Oh, there's nades.
Granata.
Granata number one, two.
I'm gonna check behind us.
It's fucking Catalyst.
They're never gonna fucking fight.
This guy just made a double door.
Oh, is that one knock?
No, they killed a player.
I'm gonna get this door.
And then this door.
And then I'm gonna put...
I'm gonna put spikes right here.
Why am I lagging?
Again?
I'm always lagging.
Where are they?
I don't know where.
They got Crypt ulted.
That shit's crazy.
I'm gonna put all the spikes below us.
Not above us.
Look at this shit.
You get zoned and then what?
You sit here.
No bats, none.
I have...
Four bats.
You have six bats.
I got one number four.
Oh, I hear your bat.
Thank you.
Oh, look.
Reemploy, reemploy.
They're gonna take it.
Yeah, they made it.
Come on, come on then.
You're going to our left here?
You're going to the nut.
They landed on the nut.
Yeah, they're gonna nut.
Huh?
They're gonna nut.
They're going to nut.
20 flesh!
Where?
Nut?
Oh yeah, they're nutting.
Wait, numbnuts died.
They fight...
They can bleed!
Who would've thought?
How the fuck did you...
How did they die in this lobby?
We need a water review.
How do you die to fucking VTubers?
Fucking VTubers?
How do you die?
It's so embarrassing.
That is so embarrassing.
God.
I know, you went to pro league.
How do you die?
That's like Swede dying to a VTuber.
I know, that's so embarrassing.
So embarrassing.
Fuck, I'd never die to a VTuber.
Okay.
Active pro dying to VTubers is crazy.
It's like dying to an Overwatch player.
One of the most accomplished IGLs in the world dying to a VTuber is actually like just...
You died to an Overwatch player too.
You died to a VTuber and an Overwatch player.
I didn't.
Yes you did, you died to Surefour.
Yeah, but I died to an Overwatch player.
I didn't die to a pro Overwatch player.
Yeah, so you died to both Apex and...
I didn't die to a VTuber.
No, no, no.
Surefour killed me, therefore I died to an Overwatch player.
He has a VTuber model that he doesn't use, therefore he's not a VTuber.
He uses it every Wednesday.
What the fuck?
He changed.
I remember when he was like...
I don't want to use it.
I don't want to.
Yeah, so you did die to a VTuber.
Oh, he's low.
He's fresh.
No, back then he wasn't a VTuber, so he didn't count.
Which one, Ditto?
Who's low?
I'm just getting inside the building.
Look at these guys.
What are you guys walking in the open for, huh?
Or just teleporting in the open more like it?
Can I just grief?
Like I really want to just grief.
Grief who?
These guys.
Make sure there's nobody behind us.
Yeah, you guys just make sure that...
I'm gonna grief.
Alright, I'm gonna...
Wait, what?
Oh.
Yeah, they're fighting here.
Like this is so third party opera, but...
Okay, okay, I'm ready.
I'm looking.
I'm heading over.
And I'm cooking.
I'm looking and I'm cooking.
Actually, you can... Yeah, we'll stay up here.
One HP on one.
Wait, he's so low.
They're all low.
No one died.
They had to...
We keep these guys out.
I'm gonna look behind us.
You guys...
How did I not break the door?
I wanna make sure nobody comes behind us.
Cause we've had that happen too many times.
I'm having a dorky moment.
They're running out on me.
I'm looking back to help.
I can't.
I don't understand his movement.
Purple?
Coming up, coming up the ramp.
Coming up the ramp.
Yeah.
They're coming up here.
Yeah, I saw them walking up.
This is my old weather.
I wanna fight this team.
I want them dead.
Okay.
Are they up the ramp?
I don't see them.
I don't know if they're below or...
Oh, fucking below.
Yeah, they went below.
Come on, pick it.
Wait, there's a guy still there.
Is this guy still in the building?
Wait, what?
Yeah, I saw a guy.
There's a guy literally right inside.
There's three people below.
I guess that's a rat.
It has to be a rat, right?
He's like, literally he's inside.
Purple?
He's still in zone.
There's two guys.
I think.
Be careful.
What is that bag over there?
They came up.
There's two guys.
He's behind.
They're behind.
They're way behind.
They're in zone.
I'm looking at them.
There's no way they got meds for that.
You guys don't got the facilities for that big man.
Right here?
I'm ping.
They're under bridge.
Oh, they went so far.
We kill.
They're fighting there.
Up here.
I'm gonna look for these guys in zone first.
I'm looking at them in zone.
They're still in zone.
Yeah, they're right here.
We're at ping.
There's no way they have meds for this.
I hit them once so they'll die.
If they die...
Wait, someone died to ring.
Is that them?
Oh, no, no, no.
I see him.
He's playing off.
I hit him for the purple.
He's running right side.
Okay.
What the fuck is he doing?
I don't know.
He's right below me.
He's fighting me.
I can't see him.
I can't see.
He's teleporting for me.
Jesus Christ.
Come help me.
Let's kill this guy.
He's gonna kill me.
He went to the right.
Nice.
I got him.
He must have meds.
Peem over here where I'm looking at.
I knocked one.
Okay.
I'm gonna push.
Where are you?
Wait, I might be dead to zone.
I live, bitch.
Nice.
Let's go.
Fuck him up.
I'm looking behind.
I wanna make sure that nobody walks up to us.
No mercy this game.
No mercy.
I'm looking for over there.
Over there.
One team.
New team.
They're flying.
I'm looking.
Are you flying with me?
I'm coming.
I'm running low on heavy ammo.
Red armor on my left.
Ditto, watch for me.
Okay.
That's a whole team behind.
I don't have heavy ammo.
I don't have heavy ammo either.
I'm gonna change.
There's a lot of light ammo here.
This three-man team is here, right?
Yeah.
They're fighting each other.
I knocked one.
I'm past my game.
Flash.
Flash on lifeline.
Focus this team.
This team is like two down, I think.
I think they're full dead, aren't they?
No, no, no.
They're not.
Because I knocked one.
I didn't get the kill.
He's right below me here.
Okay.
Yeah, scan.
Yeah.
I'm gonna scan.
Scan.
I'm gonna cover you from this team, but I need energy ammo.
It's just this guy down here.
Do you need help?
No.
This guy's just running.
I want to find... Is there energy ammo?
Oh, wait.
There might be people below us.
I don't want to risk it.
This bot is here solo.
His teammates are still crawling.
I hear a support.
Over there.
We don't want to stun the team.
Okay.
I don't have energy ammo anymore, so...
I need to chill.
I have 120 and... I can give it to you, Tom.
Okay.
Thank you.
I still didn't get my kill.
Like, he's still just crawling.
Yeah, I didn't get anything.
I'm just going to kill him as well.
This guy's going for the package.
He's got red armor.
I'm so laggy.
That's insane.
How am I supposed to hit that teleporting looking ass?
One guy in the way.
Oh, there he is.
Where am I getting shot from?
I'm out of heavy ammo completely.
I have heavy.
I can give you.
Okay.
I might get walked up on...
I hear Zip.
I have spikes though, so...
Yeah.
Should we find... they also have spikes below us.
Wait, hold up.
I'm going to throw my Havoc here with like 30 bullets...
No, Havoc.
Sorry.
There's someone down here.
Yeah, that's part of the scene.
Okay.
I'm going to play Sentinel to poke.
Somebody's flying... flying here.
They're flying below.
They're flying right here.
I might fight.
They're all the way down here.
There's more... oh, I'm going to take that.
60 on this Newcastle.
I'm going to look here.
I'm going to look here because I don't have a spike here for us.
There's people smoking.
I'm going to scan.
Hallelujah grenade.
Okay, a quick one.
Let's see if I can grab some of those here.
No, just block over there.
Okay, they're fighting like crazy.
Oh, I missed that.
They're fighting here.
Was there a six times scope anywhere?
Uh...
I don't think so.
I don't know, honestly.
I didn't check.
I remember seeing one.
There's a team here.
Right below us.
There's a team here that's crafting.
Oh my god, a lot.
A lot of people but I don't have ammo.
Oh my god, this guy is one shot.
This guy has red armor.
Oh, I have two mags left.
I'm going to stop.
I can't poke anymore.
This guy is one.
Nice.
Team here, one ping.
They're fighting here too.
I can't do anything.
This team is smoking us.
And he's shooting me as well.
Are you cheating, bastard?
This team has to come to us.
Just watch only that team that's shooting.
Only that team.
You guys watch that, I'll watch everything else.
Yeah, I'm watching here.
Both of you watch here.
There's two teams.
One to the right and one in front of me, Ditto.
Okay, okay.
This team is moving to the right.
Are they both moving to the right?
They're both moving to the right.
Yeah.
I hate lag.
Okay, that should have hit.
I don't want to waste ammo.
I'm just...
They're crafting here.
70.
They dropped to the left.
Okay, so they're not coming for us.
No.
This Puffin is 70.
I'm getting maggot drill.
Wow, this game went on longer now that there's like, you know...
No one of the pro team is alive.
Isn't that crazy?
That's pretty crazy.
Yeah.
That the pro team isn't killing everybody.
That's how it works.
I got scan right below me.
Let's see.
Where are the other doors?
I'm literally draining everyone's fucking meds.
I have one.
Nice.
I missed.
That is an embarrassment for my family.
I can't shoot anymore.
I don't have ammo.
That's fine.
You don't have to shoot.
Save it for the last string.
There's so many people dying that I want to shoot.
There's people up here.
Do you have a nade?
There's a guy behind this box alone, I think.
Yeah, I can.
I have a nade.
Which one?
The nade right here.
You see this box right here?
This blue box?
Yeah.
Oh, I see him.
Cracked him.
Nice.
Dead.
He has teammates somewhere.
Nice, we got it.
Nice.
Go to my right.
We literally have prio zone.
Oh my god.
I'm so scared of falling down.
So don't fall.
Wouldn't it be funny?
They're running out here?
Yeah.
What's on this fuck?
Yeah?
If you just stop teleporting for a second so I can hit you.
Alright, no more shooting.
Okay, but what if like...
Mobby rising here?
No, not rising.
They're just calling in mobs.
88 on this guy.
88 again.
He's rising, he's rising.
Oh my god, that was so close.
How did he get it off?
That was so close.
What the fuck?
That's crazy.
Oh god, I wanna shoot so bad.
They're running out here.
120 headshot.
Right below me, 120 headshot, Bangalore.
Okay.
I have two nades.
I'm just gonna wait.
He's literally on the bank.
Oh my god, how did he...
How is Stewie not blind?
Hello.
I can't hit.
We're like last to jump down, I think.
I'm here.
Nice.
Where?
95 headshot there.
One team here.
They have a zip on us.
What the fuck are you doing?
What the fuck are they doing?
Are you guys okay?
Like what?
I'm...
Just a surprise.
They just died, right?
Yeah, he died for that.
I was like, what?
I'm gonna Bangalore.
I'm gonna place some spikes down there.
That's yours, right?
Yeah, here, here.
I will scan.
Okay, they're all right below us.
We can like...
That is definitely not yours this time.
Why are you shooting at me, bro?
We're gonna jump down and wall, okay?
I'm smoking everything.
He got Nox.
Come with me, come with me.
I need a wall.
Wall is up.
On me, on me.
I'm dead.
Come play my nook.
Playing my nook.
No.
I have hit.
It's up to you, Ditto.
Behind you!
It's fine.
Nice try.
I forgot to nade.
I had two nades too.
I should've just threw my nades down there.
Why did they just zip when I was... That was crazy.
That zip was actually crazy.
What was that?
I was so confused.
I was like, what?
Did that actually happen?
I was like, no, they're not gonna take it all the way.
I stared at him for two seconds, because I thought he was gonna get off the zip.
But then he kept going, so I shot him.
I was like, wait, what?
I mean, nine kills last game.
You showed some dominance.
I'm just saying.
Bro, the boys got fixed 16.
What are you...
There's a team below us that got 16.
Okay.
That's Lingzer, isn't it?
Yeah, it's Lingzer.
Those players don't count.
All the LG players should lose all their points and should all go to us instead.
It's so true.
GG's, guys.
I don't even know what placement.
What placement did we get?
Let me check.
Is it updated?
It's not.
It's not updated.
Not yet?
No, it did.
Game six.
Yeah.
Hey, we got third.
Hey!
How the fuck did we get...
Oh no, that means you have to do an interview.
How did we get third from that?
I'll take it.
We got third from a second place.
That's actually crazy that we got third.
Nah.
Do we have to do an interview?
Do we have to?
I thought the interview was only for...
I nominated you for an interview.
No, I nominate RPR.
No, no, no, no.
I have to go in four minutes!
Yeah, yeah.
Well, you know, you invited me to this tournament.
You're the team leader.
You should just totally like...
You said yes.
You agreed.
No, no, no, no.
Wait, Ditto, Ditto, Ditto.
You should do the interview.
Why?
Do we need to...
Yeah.
...do an interview?
Yes.
No.
What do you mean no?
I'm not good at interviews.
If I do an interview, I'm gonna go say some super shit.
Let RPR do it.
Dude, there's no way they're gonna interview the third place team.
There's no need to.
Yes.
I think he... they will interview only first place.
Yeah, that's true.
Right.
They're not gonna...
Yeah, why would anyone talk to us?
Yeah, they already talked to like people already.
Yeah, like whatever.
Talk to the LGS players abusing RPR.
Yeah, exactly.
Talk to the numbnuts guys.
Yeah, talk to them.
Talk to them.
Do to them.
They deserve it.
Fucking shame them.
Yeah, whoa!
Shame them.
Whoa!
Shame.
I didn't say that.
They deserve it.
Alright.
Are we actually...
Shame.
Do we actually have to do the interview?
I don't know.
I actually have no clue.
I have no clue.
I didn't even read the rules of the tournament.
Okay, to be fair, I have read the rules.
I don't even know.
Alright, let's see.
Where's the rules?
Questions.
Okay, rules.
I'm QLG champion.
No, I'm not.
Tournament expert.
I'm not.
No champion.
I'm third place.
Yeah.
I'm just third place.
We're third place.
I'm not a champion.
Oh my god.
Boyspace have a lot of points.
Like twice.
Oh, there's no interviews.
There's no interviews.
Let's go.
Alright, GG's everybody.
GG's.
We did it.
Third place.
Wow, GG's are so fun.
Wow.
We're so good at this game.
GG's guys.
We got third place.
Hey, hey.
Wasn't even trying.
Got third place.
Wow.
Yeah, wasn't even trying.
Team Slightly Manjera.
We're going crazy.
Team... team... team's not slightly anymore here, Manjera.
Anyway, TSM is going to disband.
Ditto and I...
Yeah.
Dets and I are going to look for a new IGL, we figured.
Yeah, if you guys want to... if you guys want to make some like fan art of like us like disbanding, like I'm going to go to Dark Zero from now on.
So this is going to be our last tournament.
Yeah, like this is Tiro RPR's last tournament as TSM.
We are disbanding now because Ditto and I got better.
So we're not Manjera anymore.
So he has to go to Dark Zero.
Yeah, so like if you guys want to memorize this moment for the end of eternity, you guys can make some fan art if you want.
But just know that I'm leaving because I just need a better environment.
Because...
This environment is too toxic for me.
And I just don't think we can win like this.
So I just got to do what's better for my career.
And I think moving to Dark Zero is actually going to give me a chance to win from now onwards.
And like we think as TSM, the last two members in TSM...
we believe that like Imperial RPR was too much of an anchor.
So we will be trailing new IGL starting next week.
Yeah, and also as an IGL, I just can't believe that I'm IGLing and I'm also outputting more damage than Verhulst and Repz together.
Like they output 7000 damage together and I output 8000 damage from my IGLing.
Like this is insane.
Like this is why I need better teams.
That's why I need gen-raw.
I'm also tired of IGLing.
I just want to frag out because I really have the talent for it.
And I just want to go to like an IGL and just tell me what to do.
And I got teammates that do a ton of damage because my team just doesn't do shit.
You do a lot of damage because you are IGL because you know when to shoot.
Exactly, we don't know.
And if we didn't listen to your order and if we shoot, you are gonna mad at us.
Yeah.
You guys are not shooting enough anyway.
How do you guys never have ammo?
How do you never have ammo but do no damage?
You don't tell us.
Because you are taking the ammo.
Yeah, you are taking the ammo.
You guys never have ammo and never have damage.
You are always yelling for light ammo.
So I don't have light ammo anymore.
Now listen, you guys can see what the problem of TSM is right here right now.
It's a toxic ammo.
It's a toxic environment.
And I think Dizzy is just a better environment for me where I can really shine as a player.
GG's guys, we got third place.
GG.
GG's guys.
I gotta go plan for WrestleTuber now.
I'll see you guys later.
GG's.
Yeah, peace out.
Bye bye.
Alright guys, I gotta go fucking zoom for WrestleTuber now.
So...
Oh my gosh.
I can't even use my head right now.
What was my outro?
Guys, what was my outro?
I actually forgot my outro.
Uh...
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, there's WrestleTuber later on.
I'll see you guys soon everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.